donc je vous propose d'ouvrir la séance
donc là séance est ouverte
chers collègues nous avons le plaisir
aujourd'hui d'accueillir monsieur rafale
Glucksmann député européen et qui est
président de la commission spéciale du
Parlement européen sur la gérance
étrangère dans l'ensemble des processus
démocratiques de l'Union européenne y
compris la désinformation vous comprenez
bien monsieur vous remercie tout d'abord
pardon de vous être rendus disponible
une deuxième fois puisque vous avez des
difficultés pour la première audition
avec les grèves ce que nous comprenons
ce que nous comprenons bien évidemment
votre audition était parfaitement
naturel vu la nature de vos travaux vous
avez commencé avant notre représentation
nationale au niveau européen et au-delà
du travail d'ensemble de l'analyse
globale que vous avez fait des menaces
d'ingérence ou des réalités d'ingérence
qui frappent nos démocraties européennes
cette audition va aussi ouvrir une
séquence dans laquelle nous devrons et
nous pourrons aussi s'intéresser au
phénomène du cathargate évidemment qui a
frappé l'Union européenne qui rentre en
résonance le Parlement européen pardon
qui rentre en résonance avec d'autres
drames qui ont frappé notre différente
démocraties occidentales depuis
différentes années mais aussi les moyens
sur la base de cette expérience à la
fois de votre commission mais aussi des
difficultés que nous avons tous
traversés ces différentes années les
solutions qui ont été mises en place
tout au parti les manquements comment
nous pourrions améliorer évidemment les
moyens de nos démocraties pour se
protéger
la commission spéciale que vous présidez
a remis à premier rapport en janvier
2022 ce rapport a été adopté en séance
en session plénière le 9 mars 2022
et elle a été en fait recréée
immédiatement après ce que nous pouvons
pas faire nous ici elle se nommait un G1
devenant un G2 et elle poursuit donc ces
travaux et nous serons heureux d'avoir
donc votre témoignage votre analyse à la
fois sur les travaux que vous avez fait
valider par les instances européennes
mais aussi dans la mesure du possible je
ne connais pas les règles de
confidentialité auxquelles vous êtes
soumise sur cette commission dans la
mesure du possible les évolutions des
travaux que vous avez fait sur la
deuxième commission et évidemment dans
le contexte que nous connaissons si bien
international européen
vous avez aussi vous allez pardon faire
paraître prochainement un ouvrage qui
s'appelle la grande confrontation
comment Poutine fait la guerre à nos
démocraties qui sont sans doute fondées
sur les travaux que vous avez réalisés
votre expérience et donc aussi peut-être
vous pouvez me partager l'analyse que
vous souhaitez faire dans ce sans
vouloir évidemment diffuser le contenu
et nuire à son lancement mais enfin je
pense que des analyses qui sont
intéressantes pour nous tous c'est
audition n'est pas sous huis clos elle
est retransmise en direction le site de
l'Assemblée nationale l'enregistrement
vidéo sera ensuite disponible à la
demande naturellement elle est ouverte à
la presse monsieur gustahan vous
laisserai la parole pour une
intervention liminaire d'une quinzaine
de minutes dans la mesure du possible à
l'expérience de nos auditions
précédentes si vous pouvez veiller à
respecter ce temps là pas d'une manière
strict mais c'est vrai qu'on a eu des
interventions qui étaient très longues
et il est difficile pour moi par
courtoisie d'interrompre ceux qui nous
font le plaisir de venir partager avec
nous leur témoignage et leur information
mais si vous pouvez essayer voilà pour
que tout le monde parle il y a beaucoup
de commissaires aujourd'hui donc il y
aura sans doute beaucoup de questions
vous aurez ensuite des interrogations de
votre serviteur de madame la rapporteur
conscience le grip et des différents
commissaires monsieur Gluzman je vous
rappelle que selon l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires les personnes
auditionnées par une commission
d'enquête doivent prêter serment de dire
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité aussi je vous invite monsieur
Glucksman a levé la main droite et à
dire je le jure
la personne qui vous accompagne
sera-t-elle susceptible d'intervenir
donc pas juré je vous remercie et vous
avez donc la parole pour eux une
intervention préliminaire
merci monsieur le Président merci chers
rapporteur merci aux membres de la
commission merci de votre invitation
je vais bien sûr m'exprimer ici
au nom aussi de la commission spéciale
du Parlement européen sur les ingérences
que je préside depuis son lancement
pendant de trop longues années nos
gouvernants et nos élites de manière
générale on fait preuve de naïveté
d'indolence de légèreté quand aux
attaques et aux menaces qui pesaient sur
notre souveraineté pendant trop
longtemps nous avons laissé faire
laisser se produire des ingérences mener
par des régimes étrangers au cœur même
des démocraties européennes
cette commission elle a été créée pour
rompre avec cette naïveté la Commission
du Parlement européen pour rompre avec
cette naïveté c'est indolence cette
légèreté
j'ai dès le premier jour de mon mandat
en 2019 proposé la création d'une telle
commission pourquoi parce que je n'en
pouvais plus de la surprise feinte ou
réelle quand derrière des événements
politiques majeurs ont retrouvé la main
du régiment russe par exemple dans le
brexit en 2016 dans les élections
américaines de 2016 mais aussi au cours
des élections françaises présidentielles
de 2017 avec le moment que dont vous
vous souvenez tous je suppose toutes et
tous c'est à dire le moment des Macron X
et du hacking de la campagne électorale
présidentielle d'Emmanuel Macron
et cette naïveté cette indolence cette
légèreté mettait en danger nos processus
démocratiques et l'idée que j'avais en
entrant au Parlement européen c'était
justement de pousser à avoir une
approche systémique de ces menaces et
non plus simplement un moment de
surprise à chaque fois qu'on
s'apercevait que des mains étrangères
pénétraient au cœur de nos processus y
compris électoraux
la Commission spéciale sur les
ingérences étrangères dans les processus
démocratiques de l'Union européenne et
né le 23 septembre 2020 elle est fondée
elle a été créée sur la base d'une
résolution adoptée par la plénière du
Parlement européen le 18 juin 2020
depuis nous avons auditionné plus de 150
experts nous avons
fait des auditions publiques des
auditions à huis clos nous avons aussi
multiplier les missions sur le terrain
nous avons été en Ukraine nous avons été
à Taïwan nous avons été en Australie
pour essayer de comprendre comment
d'autres démocraties faisaient face aux
ingérences étrangères nous avons aussi
été à Paris nous avons rencontré des
gens que vous avez auditionnés dans
votre commission d'enquête notamment le
secrétaire général monsieur bouillon
aussi le directeur de vigenum Monsieur
Ferriol et nous avons multiplié les
missions dans les différents pays
européens pour essayer de comprendre
comment chaque pays européen faisait
face à ces ingérences quelle était la
nature de la menace et quelle était la
nature de la réaction des autorités
nationales
nous avons adopté un premier rapport le
9 mars 2022 sur la base de notre
première
commission un G
il a été adopté d'une manière très large
au Parlement européen et il établissait
pour la première fois un diagnostic
général sur l'état de la menace et au
bout de tous ces travaux nous sommes
aboutis nous avons abouti à la
conclusion qu'il existait deux types de
puissance qui s'ingère dans nos
démocraties
le premier type d'un gérance c'est
finalement une continuation des
opérations d'influence
et le but de ces ingérences c'est de
faire en sorte par des moyens licites ou
illicites que l'on parle le mieux
possible de la puissance qui s'ingère
typiquement vous avez le cas du
catargate
qui a visé le Parlement européen ou de
la caviar diplomatie qui a touché le
Conseil de l'Europe et qui était
l'oeuvre cette fois-ci de l'Azerbaïdjan
l'idée c'est par des moyens de
corruption en l'occurrence de faire en
sorte que on ne s'exprime pas contre par
exemple les violations des droits
humains au Qatar au Parlement européen
qu'on bloque les résolutions sur la
Coupe du Monde ou qu'on accélère des
processus de ratification type
accorde d'aviation ou accords de pêche
pour un autre pays comme le Maroc qui
était concerné par le qatargate
ou alors pour le Conseil de l'Europe le
but c'était qu'on ne vote pas un rapport
sur les prisonniers politiques en
Azerbaïdjan
ça c'est une continuation de l'influence
un état veut que nos institutions
parlent de manière positive de sa
politique ou de l'état de sa société
il y a un autre type aujourd'hui
d'ingérence qui s'est développé
et qui vise non pas à vendre un pays
mais à déstabiliser nos démocraties
ce type d'ingérence qui est nouveau et
d'abord l'oeuvre du régime russe depuis
de longues années le but là n'est pas
simplement qu'on parle de manière
positive de la Russie ou qu'on nommait
de dénoncer les crimes du régime russe
le but est de déstabiliser nos
démocraties et de semer le chaos dans
nos sociétés
à cette fin nous avons analysé la
manière dont procédait ce régime russe à
cette fin la fin du chaos qui a été
exposée de manière très claire par le
stratège du régime russe qui s'appelle
monsieur sourcoff et qui a théorisé tout
ce que nous allons aborder et qui
explique que le but du régime n'est pas
qu'on le croit mais qu'on cesse de
croire à la présentation officielle des
choses par les démocraties européennes
et bien les méthodes utilisées pour
aboutir à cette fin sont multiples il y
a d'abord évidemment et je pense qu'on
en discutera la manipulation de
l'information
le cas
le plus clair et celui de l'Internet
research et John C créé par Monsieur
Prigogine à Moscou qui est une immense
ferme à troll et dont le but est de
diffuser des fake news pas seulement
dont le but est de polariser le débat
public dans nos sociétés et par exemple
pour illustrer l'objectif et bien les
trolls de Monsieur Prigogine vont à la
fois soutenir aux États-Unis le hashtag
black livesmater et le hashtag allive
matters ou blue life matters donc les
deux hashtags opposés en Espagne ils
vont à la fois soutenir la cause des
indépendantistes catalans et la cause
des nationalistes
castillants de Vox et ils vont soutenir
les deux en même temps
donc ça illustre bien que le but n'est
pas tant de répondre un message mais de
semer le chaos en polarisant nos
sociétés
il y a comme autre méthode et bien les
cyber attaque et ça c'est quelque chose
qui est qui est fondamental et sur la
sur laquelle on sait longuement penché
c'est ce qui
rapproche le plus si vous voulez
cet état de guerre hybride d'un état de
guerre réelle
les cyberattaques visent nos
institutions vous avez fait l'expérience
à l'Assemblée nationale très récemment
nous aussi au Parlement européen et à
chaque fois c'est lié à une résolution
qui est votée par l'Assemblée en
l'occurrence c'était sur l'eau de mort
et la reconnaissance du génocide
au Parlement européen c'était sur la
résolution qui
stipulait que la Russie était un état
sponsor du terrorisme et qui qualifiait
le groupe Wagner de groupe terroristes
et donc on a eu le même type d'attaque
que l'Assemblée nationale mais ces
attaques visent aussi des
infrastructures civiles qui ne sont pas
des institutions par exemple les
hôpitaux il y a le cas de l'hôpital de
Corbeil-Essonnes qui a défrayé à juste
titre la chronique puisque pendant
plusieurs mois l'hôpital a été
incapacité c'est à dire qu'il y a des
conséquences extrêmement concrètes les
médecins n'ont plus accès au dossier des
malades et donc ça bloque le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital il y a le
cas de l'Agence européenne du médicament
par exemple en pleine pandémie qui a été
attaquée par des hackers russes et donc
c'est c'est cyber attaque elles sont
souvent liées à des groupes qui sont
liés au groupe les services de l'armée
de l'armée russe et elle
fond basculer si vous voulez la question
des ingérences dans la question de la
guerre hybride et elles effacent la
différence qui est constitutive de notre
analyse du monde entre états de paix et
état de guerre comment vous qualifiez
vos relations avec un régime qui attaque
vos hôpitaux en pleine pandémie
est-ce que c'est la paix est-ce que
c'est la guerre
et on est bien en peine de répondre à
cette question ce n'est pas la guerre au
sens classique puisque nous n'avons pas
des troupes qui s'affrontent sur le
terrain militaire mais ce n'est déjà
plus l'état de paix et le l'État ou les
relations seraient dictées par la
diplomatie et donc cette guerre hybride
elle est face aussi les distinctions
entre
intérieur et extérieur
et ça ça s'illustre notamment par le
rapport au financement des partis
politiques nous avons en Russie des
oligarques ou d'ailleurs des mouvements
de la société civile pas simplement des
partis politiques mais des oligarques et
un système autour de Vladimir Poutine
qui déversent son argent au profit
d'organisation qui participent à la vie
publique dans nos pays alors c'est
mouvement ces mouvements qui sont
financés par des régimes étrangers
peuvent l'être de manière légale c'est à
dire par des prêts par exemple le prêt
de la firsch First check Russian Bank au
Front national mais peuvent être aussi
financés et là c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à prouver puisque on tombe
dans l'illégalité et donc les
informations ne sont pas de domaine
public par le financement de micro
parties via des structures extrêmement
complexes de financement et là-dessus le
cas le plus intéressant si vous voulez
sur lequel on s'est penché et pour
lequel on a toujours pas de réponse
c'est le cas de la campagne votre livre
du brexit et le cas d'un personnage qui
s'appelle Aaron Banks qui est le plus
grand donateur de l'histoire de la vie
politique anglaise et qui a financé à
hauteur de plus de 9 millions de livres
la campagne du brexit et on arrive
toujours pas aujourd'hui à travers
à identifier de manière certaine la
provenance des fonds qui ont permis
cette donation de 9 millions de livres
parce qu'il y a tellement de structures
opaque qui
ont conduit à cette donation que c'est
extrêmement compliqué de dénouer les
fils et donc on est dans une situation
où il y a d'un côté une influence qui
est légale et de l'autre des opérations
qui sont couvertes
l'autre angle qui est l'autre méthode
qui est utilisée et là il est utilisé
par le régime russe mais aussi par le
régime chinois mais aussi par le régime
cathari c'est ce qu'on appelle nous ce
qu'on a défini comme étant la capture
des élites
la capture des élites ça passe
principalement par le fait que ces
régimes deviennent les pourvoyeurs de
retraite dorée d'anciens dirigeants
extrêmement puissants de nos démocraties
le cas le plus explicite de ça le plus
symbolique c'est le cas de gérarchoder
vous savez que l'Allemagne a décidé
d’une politique énergétique qui a
favorisé Gazprom et qui a favorisé le
régime russe qui a rendu l'Allemagne et
donc l'Europe dépendante de l'énergie
russe
tout gouvernement a le droit
légitimement élu a le droit de décider
de sa politique énergétique mais là où
ça commence à poser problème et là où ça
nous concerne dans notre commission
spéciale c'est que les gens qui ont
décidé de cette politique énergétique
qui sortait du nucléaire pour s'orienter
vers le gaz mais pas simplement vers le
gaz vers
uniquement le gaz russe puisque la
décision a été prise d'empêcher la
construction de terminaux métallier en
Allemagne c'est à dire que on se privait
d'autres sources de gaz
et les gens qui ont pris cette décision
à commencer par Monsieur garchrauder
sont ensuite partis travailler pour
gastrom le principal bénéficiaire de
cette décision et pas simplement garage
frauder
les gens aussi qui ont mis en pratique
les décisions prises par hiérarchieder
par exemple Marion Sheller que les gens
connaissent moins une garachröder Marion
Sheller qui était la bureaucrate en
charge des fonds énergétiques de la
transition énergétique au sein du
ministère de l'économie allemande et qui
est devenu dès la fin de son mandat donc
c'est elle qui était la chef d'orchestre
de cette politique énergétique concrète
et qui est devenu de la fin de son
mandat la chief lobbies de gaz Prom en
Europe
c'est un cas paroxystique si vous voulez
mais on en a répertorié des dizaines à
travers quasiment toutes les démocraties
européennes et non seulement à travers
toutes les démocraties européennes mais
qui touchent quasiment toutes les
familles politiques en Europe vous avez
un pays par exemple où ça a été
énormément pratiqué c'est l'Autriche et
en Autriche vous avez vu vous avez une
succession de chancelier qui sont
conservateurs ou de gauche et qui
tous termine dans des fonds ou dans des
entreprises énergétiques russes ou
chinoises et donc là ça pose une
question qui est vertigineuse quand ces
gens étaient en charge et prenaient des
décisions
pour qui travaillerait-il réellement
ça crée une suspicion extrêmement forte
et ça remet en cause les processus
démocratiques leur intégrité donc vous
avez différentes méthodes vous avez
aussi l'action qui
est une action cette fois-ci qui a été
beaucoup utilisée par et qui est
toujours beaucoup utilisé par le régime
chinois c'est-à-dire les investissements
dans les secteurs stratégiques dans le
but est finalement de rendre nos pays
dépendants dans les secteurs les plus
importants pour notre souveraineté
un G2 et on se penche là dessus dans le
cadre de la France vous avez par exemple
l'entreprise nuket qui
opère dans de nombreux aéroports tels
que Bordeaux Brest Quimper Toulouse
Strasbourg et qui est lié de manière
complètement
indissociable au régime et au complexe
Mitterrand industriel chinois on discute
en ce moment
de l'interdiction ou de la participation
de nuket
aux appels d'offres sur le contrôle
douanier et je veux dire il faut quand
même savoir que c'est pas anodin c'est à
dire que dans des secteurs aussi
stratégiques et y compris dans la merde
la sécurité du Parlement européen la
présence de ces entreprises et bien rend
nos institutions extrêmement vulnérables
de la même manière on a une situation où
l'entreprise Cosco qui est pareillement
liée au régime chinois investi dans tous
les ports européens aujourd'hui pas tous
au sens strict mais dans un grand nombre
de ports européens
à une époque où on a voulu contraindre
la Grèce à l'austérité et bien on a
poussé le gouvernement grec avant le
port du Pirée à Costco et le résultat de
ça ça ouvert une boîte de Pandore et on
a les investissements de Costco dans de
très nombreux ports européens et on
garde on doit garder en tête que Costco
c'est le régime chinois je vais essayer
de maintenir ma promesse de pas
m'étendre trop longtemps et de pouvoir
répondre aux questions mais
ce que ce que je veux dire c'est que
on a différentes méthodes
qui toutes conduit à un affaiblissement
de notre souveraineté
et le premier rôle des institutions
c'est de garantir l'intégrité des
processus politiques démocratiques dans
les cités dont elles ont la
responsabilité et je crois que
nous avons failli à cette tâche pendant
longtemps
j'aimerais dire pour finir
aborder deux choses la première chose
c'est que ma commission la commission
que je préside pardon à la
responsabilité du traitement des
conséquences du Cathar gate
ce scandale de corruption à pointer des
failles dans les processus du Parlement
européen et au-delà du Parlement
européen dans les protection des
institutions européennes et donc la
Commission travaille en ce moment et
discute en ce moment d'un rapport sur
l'ensemble des réformes qui doivent être
menées pour garantir la transparence
la sécurité et l'intégrité des processus
démocratiques à l'échelle européenne il
faudrait pas croire que ce type
d'ingérence qui Atari est réservé à
l'échelle européenne je pense que les
citoyens français sa pertinemment que
Paris fut une grande place
de l'ingérance cathari et que un ancien
ambassadeur du Qatar se plaignait par
exemple que la classe politique
française considère son ambassade comme
un distributeur de billets de 500 euros
c'est des propos qui ont été rapportés
dans un livre qui a fait beaucoup de
bruit en France et donc c'est c'est une
question qui qui va occuper nos débats
là pendant les prochaines semaines et on
rendra notre rapport
votre a le rapport en plénière en
juillet donc sur les conséquences du
catalyse la deuxième chose c'est que
se pencher ainsi sur la question des
ingérences et là je touche aux
ingérences russes nous fait comprendre
que
la guerre en Ukraine qui bouleverse
l'Europe depuis le 24 février 2022 n'a
pas commencé réellement le 24 février
2022 et que elle ne se limite pas aux
frontières de l'Ukraine et que quand on
parle quand on étudie quand on analyse
notre rapport au régime de Vladimir
Poutine on analyse pas simplement un
rapport à un régime étranger
on analyse un rapport à un régime qui a
fait de la conflictualité à notre égard
un élément fondateur de son existence et
cette confrontation là puisque vous avez
mentionné les secs que je publie cette
confrontation là elle est globale et
elle est
aussi intérieure à nos sociétés et c'est
ça qui est fondamentalement nouveau en
fait dans les travaux que nous menons à
l'échelle européenne et que vous menez
ici c'est que il y a plus de distinction
nette entre relation internationales et
à faire intérieur par exemple au
Parlement européen notre travail avant
qu'on existe et c'est toute une question
sur la réforme des institutions
européennes tombaient dans une forme de
trou noir puisque nous sommes ni une
commission qui traite simplement de
politique internationale ni une
commission centrée sur la politique
intérieure nous sommes les deux à la
fois parce que nous entrons dans une
période où la séparation de ces
catégories va vouloir de mon dire de
moins en moins de choses et c'est en
gros la preuve que la fin de l'histoire
qui a été le mythe dominant des années
2000 et des années 2010 et bien et
peut-être une illusion absolue que cette
période là est révolue et que
malheureusement on entre dans une
période beaucoup plus conflictuelle
beaucoup plus dur et violente que ce à
quoi évidemment nos élites nous avaient
formé pendant les années où j'étais
étudiant et donc cette commission là a
été prolongée parce qu'en fait il y a un
besoin qui se fait sentir au Parlement
européen de prendre en charge de manière
continue ces questions puisque elle ne
feront 4 de plus en plus prégnantes je
suis ravi de répondre aux vôtres
question
merci Monsieur Gluzman je ne doute pas
effectivement qu'il faille plusieurs
années plusieurs commissions pour venir
à bout même suivre les évolutions des
ingérences malheureusement
en tout cas en France on peut faire
qu'une commission donc nous allons
essayer de faire le maximum dans la
limite des de nos institutions ma
première question à la lumière justement
de vos travaux européens de votre
expérience est-ce que vous pourriez
comparer rapidement ce que vous avez
perçu de la menace ou des réalités
d'ingérence telles que vous avez
définies en France par rapport à nos
partenaires européens peut-être aussi et
les pays que vous avez visités vous avez
mentionné notamment l'Australie exemple
qui a été donné à plusieurs reprises
dans nos travaux notamment avec les
experts et les géopoliticiens et à la
lumière de cette comparaison c'est pas
juste pour faire un état des lieux
est-ce que comment vous situeriez la
France à la fois dans l'exposition des
menaces vous avez donné l'exemple des
macroniques mais peut-être comparer la
réalité
électorale concrète sans polémique de
ces X par rapport à autres attaques ou
d'autres types d'ingérence dans d'autres
processus électoraux et d'une manière
générale comment vous analysez la
riposte de la France la capacité de
notre démocratie à se protéger face à
ces incohérences que vous estimez pas
aussi vous avez fait des auditions vous
l'avez dit même proche des nôtres est-ce
que au terme de ces auditions est-ce
qu'elle vous ont sans dévoiler le
contenu parce que les machines qui sont
comme les nôtres étaient sous huit clos
mais est-ce que le sentiment général des
institutions françaises vous ont rassuré
est-ce que vous avez perçu qu'ils ont un
changement d'attitude ou un changement
de prise de conscience par rapport à au
phénomène bref comment vous analysez la
réponse institutionnelle et républicaine
de notre démocratie par rapport à nos
partenaires européens et à nos
partenaires occidentaux
alors du point de vue de merci monsieur
le Président du point de vue de la
menace je dirais que nous sommes
à égalité de menaces avec les autres
cercles de cette menace elle est globale
elle se retrouve dans tous les pays
européens que ce soit sur la capture des
élites je veux dire en France il y a des
un ancien Premier ministre qui est parti
travailler pour une entreprise
énergétique russe mais pas seulement lui
il y a aussi un ancien ministre
socialiste qui est parti travailler pour
Huawei il y a aussi
on a
on a donc les mêmes types de processus
qui ont lieu en France que dans les
autres pays européens
on a en France aussi les cyberattaques
on a en France aussi les opérations des
femmes à trolls ce qu'on a en France en
plus c'est les attaques que subissent
nos troupes dans des opérations
extérieures notamment en Afrique et au
Mali via la société Wagner de prix
gaugine et donc on a un risque
additionnel par rapport aux autres
on a sinon les mêmes types de menaces
sur notre
réaction je pense que l'échelon
politique pendant longtemps à minorer
les risques
et par contre je pense que les services
de sécurité les gens qui sont dans les
administrations ont assez rapidement
compris le danger qui pesait sur nous et
la nécessité de développer des
structures capables de réagir donc je
dirais que la France n'est pas le pays
le moins bien doté au moment où on se
parle de l'Union européenne et où le
pays qui a pris la menace la moins au
sérieux donc nous avons eu une capacité
de réaction et je pense que c'est
largement lié aussi tradition de l'État
français qui
toujours poser les questions de sécurité
comme étant central et donc il y a une
réaction nous dans nos auditions après
effectivement je peux pas révéler ce qui
nous a été déclaré à huis clos et la
manière dont fonctionne ces institutions
mais
je veux dire par rapport aux autres
auditions qu'on a réalisé avec des
structures qui parfois n'existent pas
d'ailleurs enfin donc ou qui essayent de
s'approcher des structures que nous
avons mis en place en France
je pense que la France n'est pas du tout
le pays le moins bien préparé pour faire
face par contre il y a des
questionnements qui sont d'ordre
politique c'est à dire
comment les alertes des services de
sécurité et des institutions ont été
répercutés politiquement c’est-à-dire
quel est le prix payé politiquement par
les assaillants de nos institutions
si vous avez des gens des services de
sécurité qui
identifient une menace ou une attaque
ensuite quelle est la conséquence
politique
pour les assaillants
et ça c'est c'est une question est-ce
que la France là dessus est-ce que les
autorités françaises ont été à la
hauteur je pense moi ça c'est mon avis
personnel c'est pas la commission qui
parle que on a fait preuve de beaucoup
trop de légèreté dans le traitement de
ces affaires
après il y a des pays qui ont beaucoup à
nous apprendre
et
il y a des loss vous avez mentionné
l'Australie nous on a été en Australie
sur le plan législatif l'Australie a été
un laboratoire
parce que la menace en l'occurrence la
menace principale c'était la menace du
gouvernement chinois
était devenu tel que il y a eu un
consensus bipartisan dans la classe
politique australienne pour essayer de
changer les législations alors c'est
encore trop tôt aujourd'hui pour voir à
quel point c'est législations
fonctionnent
quelles sont les conséquences concrètes
de la mise en place c'est législation ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y ait une prise
de conscience et qu'il y a de nouveaux
textes législatifs qui sont passés et
qu'on a étudié pendant longtemps
une autre démocratie qui est
à développer des politiques qui sont
extrêmement intéressantes pour nous
c'est Taïwan parce que c'est si vous
voulez
on a on a nous un nombre élevé d'attaque
visant notre démocratie mais c'est pas
au niveau de ce que subissent les
autorités taïwanaises de manière
quotidienne et donc à Taïwan le choix a
été fait de répondre par la démocratie
et
ils ont mis en place des processus
démocratiques extrêmement intéressant
et notamment une coordination avec la
société civile qui est vraiment
impressionnant et donc moi j'encourage
toujours
à développer les échanges avec Taipei
parce que c'est de tous les exemples
qu'on a croisé le long de notre chemin
avec la commission spéciale de loin je
dirais le plus impressionnant
et notamment et je vous invite enfin je
sais pas je suis pas maître de votre
agenda mais
je vous invite à échanger si c'est
possible avec Audrey Tang qui est la
ministre en charge de la démocratie
numérique et de la lutte contre les
manipulations de l'information et ils
ont développé un rapport à la démocratie
numérique qui est vraiment très
impressionnant et notamment la manière
dont il lutte contre les campagnes de
manipulation de l'information je pense
et beaucoup plus efficace que tout ce
que on a pu produire à l'échelle
européenne ou française jusqu'ici
d'autre part je le soulignais au sein
même de l'Union européenne sur les
questions justement de cyberattaque ou
de manipulation de l'information il y a
des pays qui sont en avance notamment
l'Estonie
qui nous avait alerté depuis 2007
sur les risques des attaques
dites virtuelles enfin des attaques sur
les infrastructures et des cyberattaques
et qu'on a absolument pas cru hein parce
qu'on pensait que les Estoniens étaient
obsédés par la Russie et que finalement
il revivait sans cesse leur passé donc
et deux qu'ils étaient obsédés par le
numérique et que finalement des attaques
virtuelles c'était pas très important
alors même que ce qu'ils expérimentaient
et ce qu'il dénonçait ce qu'ils
analysaient c'était la guerre du futur
et donc il y a des exemples au sein même
de l'Union européenne qui sont
extrêmement intéressants à étudier et
voilà donc je dirais qu'on n'est pas du
tout
les plus mal dotés en termes
d'institutions et de réactions
institutionnelle il y a des éléments
beaucoup plus faibles en Europe mais on
n'est pas non plus à l'avant-garde
de la lutte contre les ingérences et en
particulier sur la question des
manipulations de l'information
merci beaucoup je posterai juste une
deuxième question après je passerai la
parole parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
commissaires et je ne veux pas qu'il
soit limite dans leur parole moi je peux
rester plus donc je passerai plein de
questions après mais vous avez noté dans
dans le rapport qui a été adopté sauf si
j'ai la bonne version un élément qui m'a
beaucoup intéressé vous parlez de 300
millions d'euros c'est que j'ai bien
compris de fonds qui ont été je sais pas
comment dire injecter ou projeter dans
des phénomènes de d'ingérence c'est
intéressant parce que moi en tant que
président commission je n'ai pas les
moyens alors c'est intéressant de savoir
comment vous êtes arrivé à ce montant de
les établir est-ce que vous pouvez faire
une analyse de ce montant à quoi il a
servi oui j'avais considérant par
exemple pour que tout le monde puisse
que tout le monde n'a pas forcément le
rapport et ceux qui nous écoutent un
moment dans dans le rapport il y a
marqué considérant par exemple que la
Russie la Chine et d'autres régimes
autoritaires ont injecté plus de 300
millions de dollars américains dans 33
pays il y a des fins d'ingérence dans
les processus démocratique considérant
que l'Iran le Venezuela et d'autres
acteurs du Moyen-Orient et de l'extrême
droite américaine ont également
participé à des financements dissimulés
considérant que cette tendance
s'accélère clairement considérant que la
moitié de ses affaires concerne des
actions menées par la Russie en Europe
considérant que la corruption et le
blanchiment de capitaux sont une source
de financement politique en provenance
des pays autoritaires je trouve que ce
paragraphe est vraiment
révèle les choses particulièrement
graves non pas que le reste du rapport
ne révèle grave mais cet appareil dont
la densité m'a vraiment interpellé
est-ce que vous pourriez donc revenir
sur sur ce paragraphe sur les montants
est-ce que ce sont des informations qui
vous ont été données
comment vous avez vous êtes parvenu à
ces chiffres et est-ce que vous pouvez
peut-être expliciter
certaines lignes notamment la dernière
c'est à dire que considérant que la
corruption et le blanchiment de capitaux
sont une source de financement politique
en provenance de pays autoritaires
est-ce que cela concerne par exemple la
France est d'une manière générale est-ce
que les différentes lignes de ce
paragraphe concerne en particulier la
France je vous remercie
merci alors comme toujours les chiffres
dans ce cas-là sont extrêmement
compliqués à vérifier donc vous me
projetez au moment de la première
rédaction c'était des chiffres qui nous
avaient été donnés notamment par des
enquêteurs et il y avait eu des
publications du New York Times et donc
des enquêteurs journalistiques et des
Think tank qui avait tenté une
estimation ensuite sur les
la dernière phrase dont vous parlez ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on a
rencontré à de multiples reprises au
cours de nos travaux c'est que si vous
prenez par exemple le cas de la Russie
il y a eu une fuite massive des capitaux
depuis avant même la chute de l'URSS et
qui était d'ailleurs orchestré par le
KGB lui-même et on estime alors là c'est
des chiffres qui sont
des estimations on estime à plusieurs
c'était le
excusez-moi c'était le fond
c'était une structure officielle
américaine mais je me souviens plus
laquelle là c'est pas dans le rapport
qui avait estimé que dans c'était même
le excuse-moi c'était même le directeur
de la Banque centrale russe qui avait
estimé que sur la seule année 2012 mais
là je vous dis parce que je vous le dis
de tête non je sais à vérifier si vous
voulez je vous enverrai l'interview
traduite que sur la seule année 2012
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
dollars de milliards de dollars pardon
avait fui la Russie et que c'était les
mêmes structures
d'un contrôlés par un nombre très limité
de personnes qui contrôlaient
l'utilisation de ces fonds obscurs
il s'était gardé d'aller plus loin
puisque un des vices directeurs de la
Banque centrale avait été abattue en
pleine rue en quelques années plus tôt
pour avoir dénoncé le même type de fuite
des capitaux et on estime donc des
centaines de milliards ont fui
ouais parce que là c'était des dizaines
de milliards sur une année
donc en fait on est dans une situation
où
on a de l'argent
qui est
très difficilement traçable et qui peut
être affecté à des opérations
d'ingérence mais le régime russe n'est
pas le seul à avoir de l'argent et ce
qui est intéressant de noter c'est que
il profite des structures opaques du de
la finance internationale et donc quand
on a des
révélations sur des paradis fiscaux très
souvent on retrouve les traces de ces
régimes là et c'est la même chose que ce
que je j'ai évoquais à propos du brexit
finalement on a du mal à tracer la
provenance des fonds sur les donations
parce que il y a des structures
du capitalisme international de la
finance internationale qui permettent
cette opacité là
et c'est pour ça que quand on parle par
exemple de la question des paradis
fiscaux on ne parle pas que d'une
question de justice fiscale ou de
justice sociale on parle aussi de
menaces sur notre souveraineté puisque
si on n'arrive plus à tracer des fonds
comment peut-on se protéger contre cet
argent là et son investissement dans nos
structures qu'elle que cet
investissement soit malin ou Bénin ça on
détermine ensuite mais ça reste quand
même un immense problème et donc il y a
chez dans les institutions européennes
un vrai questionnement sur la manière
qu'on
peut avoir et bien de lutter contre ces
capitaux qui sont sortis de ces pays
mais dont on ne trace plus finalement la
destination
pardon est-ce que ça fera ça par
définition ça je peux pas vous répondre
parce que je ne sais pas à quelle fin
sont utilisés ces capitaux mais je ne
vois pas pourquoi ça fera prêt
d'autres pays plus que la France et la
France moins que d'autres pays mais j'ai
pas d'éléments pour dire que depuis tel
paradis fiscal le régime russe ou je ne
sais quel autre régime à envoyer de
l'argent en France spécifiquement
mais c'est juste pour bien répondre à la
question que je vous ai posé ce que je
veux dire c'est dans le cadre de votre
travaux vous n'avez pas eu à connaître
et des auditions que vous avez faites
une fois de plus s'agit pas de donner
des cas d'espèces ça me donner des
ordres de grandeur ou des
caractérisations vous n'avez pas eu
connaissance sur les différents points
que traitent ce paragraphe de de
phénomènes typiquement ou spécialement
français non
je vous remercie madame la rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur Glucksmann monsieur le
Président de la commission spéciale du
Parlement européen sur les ingérences et
étrangères et les interférences dans nos
processus démocratiques européens pour
votre présentation et les premières
séries de réponses élément d'information
très précis que vous nous avez apporté
moi je souhaite simplement effectivement
revenir peut-être rapidement sur deux
des quelques-uns des enseignements que
vous nous avez présenté
la première constatation donc de
travaux de 1g1 entre guillemets la
continuation de l'influence par des
moyens licites ou illicites qui est une
première
stratégie d'ingérence avec des exemples
concrets illustrés encore récemment par
le catargate ou le Maroc est par exemple
ou le cap-vergate au Parlement européen
et au Conseil de l'Europe et puis le
deuxième type d'ingérence extrêmement
violent et brutal que l'on voit à
l'oeuvre également depuis longtemps
à travers la stratégie de
déstabilisation de de
création de chaos avec la volonté à
travers toute une série d'instruments
les réseaux sociaux la manipulation de
l'information la fabrication
de faucontre
les fermatrols et autres utilisations de
médias entre guillemets qui ne sont que
des instruments de propagande Spoutnik
et RT par exemple dans le cas de la
Russie pour ne pas les nommer cette
stratégie donc de déstabilisation et de
destruction totale ça c'était la le
premier enseignement que je souhaite
mettre en lumière parce que je trouve
extrêmement intéressant est-ce que vous
avez également mis en avant comme
confusion entre l'intérieur et
l'extérieur
entre le l'état de guerre et l'état de
paix ça je pense que ce sont des
éléments extrêmement éclairants dont il
faut que nos concitoyens nos él les élus
toute personne en situation de
responsabilité dans nos démocraties a
commencé par notre démocratie soit
pleinement conscient parce que je pense
que vos travaux comme ceux que nous
essayons très modestement de mener après
d'autres sont
partis prenantes de la stratégie de
sensibilisation et de conscientisation
que nous essayons
d'insuffler sensibilisation
conscientisation mais aussi
désignation d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs qui sont plus particulièrement
présents que d'autres le rapport de la
Commission 1g1 en tout cas c'était dans
vos premières conclusions à clairement
désigner la Russie comme le principal
acteur l'un des principaux
de déstabilisation dans les processus
démocratiques
européens donc dans nos processus
internes nous est à Nation et puis et
puis les incidents européennes
elles-mêmes alors on a effectivement le
cas de ce que vous écrivez le Président
il faisait allusion donc dans l'un des
considérants du rapport à mais également
dit pour celles et ceux qui nous
regardent qui nous écoutent ou qui nous
écouterons qui s'intéressent au rapport
c'est pas 65 dans votre rapport que vous
détaillez assez précisément par exemple
la source c'est le rapport 2020 de
l'Alliance pour la sécurité de la
démocratie à un instant quand même qui
fait autorité il y a la référence très
claire à ce rapport de
prosecuring qui a effectivement tenté ce
cette globalisation des fonds d'un
montant de 300 millions de dollars des
versets dans quelques pays
annonce de la Russie de la Chine et
d'autres régimes autoritaires ou
diktatoriaux
et cela pour moitié en provenance de la
Russie vous faites également allusion et
ma question portera plus spécialement
là-dessus sur et ça corrobore des
éclairages et des informations que nous
avons mis à jour à l'occasion d'autres
auditions sur une stratégie de
d'accord et d'orchestration de
coopération serrées entre certains
milieux russes certains oligarques
russes par exemple et et assemble de
partie de la droite extrême ou de
l'extrême droite en Europe qui sont
nommément cités le parti autrichien FPE
mais il y a également la légat dans en
Italie là les gars la Ligue du Nord ou
le rassemblement national par exemple
s'agissant de la France mais il y en a
d'autres un parti finlandais etc etc
est-ce que vous vous nous en dire un peu
plus sur
la manière dont vous voyez ou dont votre
commission spéciale a pu éclairer cette
orchestration d'une stratégie de
coopération de ciblage peut-être de
financement
les sites de ces formations politiques
d'extrême droite ou de droite extrême on
a beaucoup entendu parler de ce que l'un
des oligarques russes Malo fief a
longtemps
tenté avec d'ailleurs
un succès
relatif alors qu'il s'est un petit peu
éteint évidemment après
l'entrée de l'armée russe en Ukraine le
24 février 2022 mais est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur cet
orchestration très très stratégisée très
organisé
depuis le Kremlin ou les cercles très
proches du président Poutine en
direction de de force politique très
très particulière qui appartiennent tout
au spectre je dirais de la droite
extrême ou de l'extrême droite ma
première question
merci
si vous voulez il y a une réunion qui a
eu lieu en 2014 qui dans la foulée de
l'annexion de l'agriculture de la Crimée
et d'une partie du Dombas
une réunion qui a eu lieu à Vienne
organisé par Malo FEF avec les
différentes extrêmes droites européennes
il y avait notamment le FPO monsieur
straer qui était la puissance invitante
et je crois qu'il aura le rassemblement
national était où le Front national à
l'époque hété par Monsieur choprade qui
était député européen et on avait des
représentants de tous ces différents
mouvements politiques
[Musique]
il y a eu là normalement la réunion
devait pas être publique mais il y a eu
une infiltration d'un journaliste
Autriche ou suisse allemand pardon
suisse allemand qui a fait un rapport
justement sur sur cette réunion déjà il
est intéressant de noter que cette
réunion elle se tenait officiellement
l'honneur du 2 centièmes anniversaire je
crois
de du sommet de la Sainte Alliance
qui a mis fin
l'épisode napoléonien
et qui a été initié par le tsar à
l'époque parce qu'il trouvait le Dark et
bien le gouvernement anglais qui était
le allié était bien trop libéral et
qu'il ne fallait pas simplement casser
la grande nation française mais en plus
éradiquer extirper de l'Europe tout ce
qui avait rendu possible 1789 bon ça je
ferme la parenthèse donc c'était
l'occasion de cette grande réunion
c'était la célébration de cette sainte
alliance contre la révolution française
et les principes des lumières et tous
ces représentants de des examorats
européennes ont écouté un discours de
monsieur doughin qui est le philosophe
ultra-nationaliste en vogue au Kremlin
et monsieur doudine a exhorté la mise en
place d'une révolution conservatrice
européenne
pour mettre fin à la soumission de
l'Europe aux États-Unis pour mettre fin
à
l'Europe qu'il est qualifie de maritime
c'est-à-dire libérale et enfin avoir
l'alliance des peuples contre les
institutions européennes
et cette stratégie là elle a été une
constante du régime russe et ces
mouvements qui peuvent avoir ces
mouvements européens qui peuvent avoir
des positions sur les questions sociales
différentes sur les questions
économiques il y en a qui sont très très
libéraux d'autres qui sont beaucoup plus
sociaux et bien leur point commun leur
point de ralliement c'était leur soutien
à la politique du Kremlin leur soutien à
l'annexion de la Crimée leur soutien
aux positions aussi
conservatrice de Vladimir Poutine sur
les mœurs ces grands discours sur la
décadence
occidentale et ça ça a touché vraiment
tous ces mouvements en France en Italie
en Autriche en Allemagne avec la FD
aussi vous avez pas mentionné
et et
ces mouvements là
ont certes
changer si vous voulez de discours en
2022 face à l'invasion totale de
l'Ukraine mais ils ont été
liés à cette ambition qui était une
ambition encore une fois qui est effacée
les frontières puisque c'est plus une
relation à des pays étrangers c'est
vraiment une question qui est devenue
une question
idéologique transnationale et donc il y
a eu une adhésion à un projet
et ça tous les discours qui suivent
néfasteront pas ce moment il y a eu une
adhésion un projet et dont le but était
la remise en cause des institutions
européennes et des principes qui
constituent ces institutions
sur la question des finances moi je
distinguerai vraiment la question de
financement légal via des prêts
ça n'empêche pas qu'ensuite il y a le
même niveau d'influence sans doute mais
il y a les questions des financements
par des prêts et il y a ensuite la
question
des financements
les financements par les prêts on peut
les chiffrer on les connaît
les financements occultants on les
connaît pas par définition donc moi je
peux pas vous donner de chiffres
là-dessus ce que je sais c'est que
il y a
là contrairement peut-être à la capture
des élites il y a la question d'une
connivence idéologique de rapport au
monde
de vision du monde
et
si vous voulez le régime russe a
toujours eu une double stratégie d'un
côté on essaye d'affaiblir le centre
ce qu'on a ce qu'on appelle le système
et de l'autre côté on essaye de faire
monter les forces qui remettent en cause
ce centre et ce système et donc on est
gagnant des deux côtés a été en
instrumentalisent des mouvements qui
remettent en cause les institutions
européennes et par ailleurs on essaye au
maximum de corrompre les institutions
européennes elles-mêmes les
gouvernements les pour finalement les
affaiblir et cette stratégie là elle a
été théorisée en Russie et les
mouvements d'extrême droite ont été
instrumentalisés dans cette stratégie
d'affaiblissement des gouvernements
démocratiques et
et on peut le retrouver
illustrer par la promotion de la figure
de Vladimir Poutine comme étant un
leader fort qui répondrait à la
faiblesse des dirigeants occidentaux
vous avez tous vu les mésaventures en
Ukraine peu de temps après l'invasion
totale de du pays de Monsieur Salvini à
qui on a rappelé à quel point il
s'affichait avec
des enfin avec un t-shirt de Vladimir
Poutine et que donc il n'était pas le
bienvenu mais c'était extrêmement
répandu à ce moment-là Poutine devenait
un point de ralliement de mouvement qui
remettait en cause la décadence des
nations européennes
et encore une autre de petite question
et je vais relayer aussi des questions
de notre collègue Charles zidstool qui
ne peut malheureusement pas être parmi
nous cet après-midi pour les raisons
médicales et personnelles qui le
regrette infiniment
[Musique]
on a parlé enfin vous avez évoqué les
financements occulte que par définition
bien évidemment on ne peut pas connaître
il y a quelque chose qui n'est ni au
culte ni secret ce sont les votes les
déclarations politiques les déclarations
publiques et les votes notamment les
votes au Parlement européen
et là on a vu y compris après
l'annexion illégale de la Crimée y
compris après
l'occupation du nom basse y compris
après des événements encore plus récents
et plus tragiques comme le l'entrée de
l'armée russe en
Ukraine une certaine constance je dirais
dans des votes de la part de certains
groupes de droits d'extrême et et
l'extrême droite au Parlement européen
mais également d'autres groupes mais
également d'autres groupes qui
attestaient toujours d'une volonté de
continuer à soutenir
le narratif russe le narratif russe et
une certaine vision de de la relation
entre la Russie et l'Otan la Russie
l'Union européenne etc etc est-ce qu'à
cet égard dans ces dans ces votes là
dont
les différences scrutins sont publiques
ou tout ça et relayé abondamment sur le
site du Parlement européen sur les
réseaux sociaux partout est-ce que il y
a dans notamment dans le groupe
idée le groupe qui rassemble les
familles de politique nationale de la
droite à l'extrême droite est-ce qu'il y
a des distinctions que vous avez eu le
temps de d'établir peut-être en position
de vote entre entre certains ou est-ce
que
vous avez là une comment dire il y a un
bloc qui qui a qui affiche cette
proximité idéologique avec le régime y
compris à travers ses votes ou est-ce
qu'il y a des distinctions que vous
pourriez avoir envie de de souligner que
vous auriez en ayant une focale un peu
plus précise que la nôtre que vous
auriez envie de nous faire partager
on a vu une différence
qui s'est progressivement affirmé
notamment avec les Italiens qui qui ont
depuis qui sont au pouvoir et dans le
sur la voie du pouvoir a changé de
d'optique
mais moi je
viens ma commission n'a pas vocation à
analyser les votes parce que on peut
tout à fait voter ce qu'on veut
le vote ne prouve pas que vous êtes
instrumentalisé par par un régime
étranger
par contre
il y a d'autres actions députés
européens qui posent problème
notamment la question des visites et la
question des missions soi-disant
d'observation électorale ou là si je
prends un exemple concret
par exemple vous avez je pense
auditionné le député européen de Thierry
Mariani
du groupe du Rassemblement national donc
de idée et il a multiplié les voyages en
trimestre il y a même été sanctionné
pour une mission en 2020 je pense en
Crimée
et c'était des missions qui ne sont pas
autorisées par
qui ne sont pas validés officiellement
par le Parlement européen et qui vise à
légitimer des actes que notre
gouvernement et tous les gouvernements
européens qualifient illégaux et de
absolument illégaux
donc
c'est députés parce que Thierry Mariani
en 2020 n'était pas tout seul il y avait
aussi hervé Juvin Jeanlain La Capelle et
Nicolas Bay je pense c'était les quatre
Français qui ont été sanctionnés par le
Parlement européen ensuite et bien été
si vous voulez les cautions
du processus d'annexion de la Crimée
et donc là c'est pas une qui simplement
une question de vote je veux dire
moi je je
parle en mon nom et en tant que député
citoyen je m'opposerais à vous si vous
votez contre par exemple le fait de
d'envoyer enfin une aide militaire à
l'Ukraine c'est pas parce que vous vous
opposez à la livraison des armes que
vous êtes nécessairement un agent de
Vladimir Poutine
on a le droit d'avoir des points de vue
extrêmement différents même si je juge
que c'est un point de vue parfaitement
condamnable par contre on n'a pas le
droit de se revendiquer du Parlement
européen pour
aller justifier ou valider ou cautionner
des processus qui sont des processus
parfaitement illégaux du point de vue
droit international condamné par nos
états et nos pays et donc finalement de
servir de caution
aux entreprises du régime russe et donc
il y a des actions là qui sont
condamnables et condamnés sur la
question des votes encore une fois oui
il y a des distinctions qui sont
apparues
mais là ma commission la commission que
je préside n'a pas vocation finalement à
scruter les votes des députés qui sont
par définition libres de voter ce qu'ils
veulent
très bien merci madame monsieur est-ce
que c'est ensuite nous aurons madame
amour excusez-moi
merci le président merci chers
nous avions reçu dans une audition
précédente les journalistes ne story
killer pour Biden stories
qui nous avait évoqué d'ailleurs notre
surprise au fait de d'une organisation
assez complexe quand même de
désinformation à base d'une société qui
s'appelle team Rory qui vendait à ses
clients pouvant être effectivement des
états
étranger des campagnes de désinformation
la clé en main avec la possibilité de
diffuser cela sur sur les réseaux
sociaux et des grands moyens
au-delà de votre connaissance d'ailleurs
de ce sujet que vous pourrez peut-être
nous expliquer je voulais savoir si
comment vous voyez le combat contre ces
ingérences pas via les réseaux sociaux
est-ce que l'Europe a pris des
dispositions ou les envisages merci
merci beaucoup pour votre question
nous sommes évidemment
penchés sur les révélations de
formidable stories et c'était une
société israélienne en l'occurrence qui
vend effectivement ses services pour
organiser des des campagnes de
manipulation de l'information ce qui
implique des faux comptes des
des bottes des vrais
gens qui vise par exemple à discréditer
une opposition au moment d'une élection
ou à faire monter un candidat donc il y
a un business extrêmement juteux qui mis
en place d'un côté vous avez des
ingérences étatique et de l'autre côté
vous avez des sociétés pirates
qui se mettent au service du régime qui
leur donnerait le plus d'argent ou du
mouvement qui leur donnerait le plus
d'argent pour organiser des campagnes
des informations alors en plus si vous
ajoutez à ça les progrès de
l'intelligence artificielle vous avez un
cocktail là qui est complètement
terrible pour pour nos démocraties
l'Europe sur la première chose à faire
c'est de réguler cet espace l'espace des
réseaux sociaux qui est une sorte de Far
West au moment on se parle et là dessus
l'Europe par rapport par exemple aux
États-Unis l'Europe est précurseur dans
ce domaine avec le digital services le
DSA
qui
est étudié d'ailleurs dans d'autres
démocraties je disais tout à l'heure
qu'on étudieait ce que faisait les
autres démocraties pour lutter contre
les ingérences sur la question des
plateformes même en Australie les gens
sont extrêmement intéressés par les
efforts produits par l'Union européenne
moi je suis toujours critique sur nos
manquements pour une fois qu'on n'est
pas
en retard et qu'on est même en avance
par rapport aux autres il faut le
souligner donc là l'idée c'est de rendre
les plateformes responsables aussi de la
lutte contre ces campagnes là vous avez
des
entreprises qui font des
des bénéfices extrêmement grands il est
logique qu'elle faisait une forme de
responsabilité sur le contenu partagé et
qui leur permet de gagner autant
d'argent
donc ça c'est c'est vraiment un effort
ou si on veut que ça fonctionne il va
falloir aussi qu'on convaincre nos
partenaires d'adopter la même position
que nous et pas se réfugier derrière non
mais c'est une propriété privée à partir
du moment où ces propriétés privées sont
les nouvelles Agora publiques ce qui
laisse quand même une forme de vertige
dans l'esprit quand on considère cela
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui notre Agora
public elle est elle a lieu sur une
propriété privée
en état actuel des choses et donc il
faut impérativement réguler ses
plateformes et
mettre en place
de manière efficace les règlements que
nous avons voté à l'échelle européenne
sur
ça c'est sur les plateformes ensuite il
y a un effort extrêmement massif à
produire sur l'éducation aux médias
c'est à dire que c'est aussi sur les
citoyens qu'il faut qu'il faut agir pour
apprendre le discernement extrêmement
tôt
ça passe par l'école ça passe par
l'éducation ensuite même après l'école
et ça il y a des programmes qui sont
conçus mais je pense que c'est encore on
l'a souligné dans le rapport bien trop
faible par rapport à
l'immensité de la tâche si vous voulez
la troisième chose à faire c'est de
faire en sorte qu'il y a encore du
journalisme d'investigation dans nos
pays
c'est que si vous laissez complètement
au marché le sort de la presse en
réalité le journalisme d'investigation
va pas être rentable ça prend du temps
ça prend de l'énergie ça prend de
l'argent et donc il faut qu'on arrive à
considérer que le joint et son
investigation après ce livre qui fait
son travail c'est si vous voulez une
condition de possibilité de la survie de
la démocratie dans le monde dans lequel
on va évoluer
la
troisième enfin la quatrième chose
donc là oui pardon il y a le média
freedom Act qui va être en discussion à
aller chez le européenne et aussi le
paquet de défense de la démocratie donc
ça c'est ce qui va nous occuper là et
dans notre rapport il y a pas que des
propositions donc négatives au sens de
plus de fermeté plus de sanctions plus
de contrôle il y a aussi des
propositions positives notamment sur la
question de la presse du financement de
la presse et du journalisme d'in sur
l'éducation médias et la dernière chose
sur le rôle de la société civile
vous savez beaucoup de débats autour du
fact checking mais il y a des
organisations de la société civile avec
lesquelles il faut absolument travailler
et je pense que là dessus par exemple
par rapport à la question qui m'a été
posée tout à l'heure je pense que l'État
français a encore du travail à faire
pour mieux intégrer les organisations de
la société civile dans une réflexion
commune collective et là-dessus Taïwan
aurait beaucoup à nous apprendre et donc
ces organisations de la Société cils si
vous voulez par exemple en Europe
ont très faiblement accès à des fonds
et d'ailleurs on se retrouve parfois
dans des situations complètement
paradoxales ou c'est des de l'argent
américain qui va aider à des ONG qui
luttent contre des ingérences
en Europe moi je trouve pas ça normal je
trouve que il devrait y avoir des fonds
européens qui permettent de mener cette
lutte en Europe pour des organisations
de la société civile européenne et donc
on a eu beaucoup de discussions
là-dessus
c'est toujours un problème quand il faut
trouver des financements mais c'est un
enjeu majeur et c'est un enjeu qui ne
fera que grandir
je sais pas si vous avez vu je suppose
que oui les dernières productions
d'intelligence artificielle par exemple
sur la photo du pape
avec sa doudoune qui ressemblait à un
rappeur
et bien cette photo elle a la
circulation partout et là en
l'occurrence c'est pas très grave c'est
le pape avec une doudoune mais ce que ça
montre c'est que s'il y a pas de
traçabilité à imposer c'est-à-dire si on
peut pas
tracer ces images qu'on ne peut pas voir
d'emblée que c'est de l'intelligence
artificielle et bien comment on va faire
pour avoir un débat public serein qui
repose sur des faits qui soient partagés
par tous ça va être de plus en plus
compliqué nous dans nos missions et je
peux pas rentrer trop dans le détail
là-dessus puisque c'est ça faisait
partie des réunions qu'on a eu qui était
pas publique
mais nous avons eu accès à des logiciels
de fabrication de campagne de
désinformation de manipulation
d'information par exemple grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle vous dites
on va
discréditer la députée le grip
au hasard voilà non je sais pas pourquoi
elle mais sur lequel je suis tombé on
peut le faire sur n'importe qui et vous
avez une campagne parfaitement
organiser
avec franchement très peu de différence
avec ce que mon esprit pourrait produire
même
qui vient en quelques minutes
[Musique]
vous avez une autre question Nadège à
bamangoli
merci merci monsieur le député pour
votre exposé moi j'aurais une question à
trois pas trois questions en une sur
l'un sur le Qatar et sur sur l'OTAN dans
votre précédent rapport vous faisiez un
focus particulier sur sur la Russie et
sur la Russie la Chine a juste titre
entre temps il y a eu le Qatar get
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure vous expliquer
que la France fut une place une forte
place de l'influence qatari d'ailleurs
c'est quoi la situation aujourd'hui
entre temps vous avez entamé d'autres
travaux est-ce que vous avez du coup pu
examiner la situation d'autres États qui
aujourd'hui
agissent parfois pour s'immiscer dans le
fonctionnement démocratique et notamment
culturel à travers des enjeux
civilisationnels je pense à l'Inde hier
lors d'un des débats sur sur la menace
terroriste extrême droite on nous a
confirmé que cet état participait
activement à la diffusion de masse de
fausses informations
l'instinct avec lesquels on a de bonnes
relations diplomatiques avec lesquelles
on entretient des relations commerciales
notamment du point de vue de l'armement
est-ce que vous avez ou vous allez vous
intéresser à ce pays d'autant que le
président maudit vient en France le 14
juillet autre question sur sur l'OTAN
vous avez indiqué qu'une coopération
avec l'OTAN pouvait être intéressante
dans la lutte contre les ingérences
étrangères comment est-ce que vous
pouvez concilier ça vous pensez qu'on
peut concilier cela avec le fait que
l'OTAN est multiple et notamment
avec sa présence de la Turquie et de la
Hongrie de quelle manière est-ce qu'on
peut avoir un mécano en la matière ça
m'intéresse particulièrement parce que
je suis membre de l'association
il y a une commission démocratie et qui
s'intéresse également à tous ces sujets
là donc je voulais savoir comment vous
envisagez les choses
merci merci beaucoup
pour la question
alors le Qatar on l'avait déjà mentionné
dans le dans le premier rapport et
et on avait juste pour expliquer
pourquoi est-ce que la focale était
surtout sur la Russie et la Chine parce
que
les ingérences russes et chinoises ont
cette spécificité par rapport aux autres
qu'elle vise à la déstabilisation de nos
démocraties
ce qui veut pas dire que les autres
soient acceptables du tout c'est juste
une échelle et on a aussi travaillé au
cours de nos auditions sur l'Inde
on a fait même une audition spécifique
sur l'Inde et il y a eu notamment
une question assez sérieuse posée sur
les sur les
c'est dans le rapport d'ailleurs final
il y a le passage sur l'Inde et sur la
question notamment de l'invitation on
retombe toujours là-dessus mais c'est
c'est une question fondamentale en fait
de l'invitation par le gouvernement
indien de député y compris députés
européens et aussi la question des
fausses ONG ou des faux médias mis en
place par les réseaux nationalistes
indiens alors là tout de suite je sais
pas si on va se repencher sur l'Inde
parce que on est vraiment focalisé sur
la question du catargate des suites donc
c'est plutôt le Qatar et le Maroc en ce
moment qui sont l'objet de nos travaux
donc la question que vous avez posée sur
l'OTAN elle est extrêmement intéressante
parce que à la fois il y a une expertise
au niveau de l'OTAN qui est puissante
sur la question de la guerre hybride ils
sont extrêmement intéressants les
experts de l'OTAN sur cette question là
et en même temps c'est vrai que la
question de la Turquie est une question
essentielle alors là Hongrie que vous
mentionnez c'est un problème fondamental
mais c'est pas simplement dans le temps
parce que c'est aussi dans l'Union
européenne qu'on voit à chaque Conseil
européen à quel point c'est difficile de
devoir gérer
le gouvernement Orban et à quel point
les ingérences d'ailleurs russes et
chinoises en gris sont extrêmement
fortes mais sur la question de la
Turquie c'est que c'est aussi une
puissance d'ingérence dans nos pays
à travers des associations pictuelles à
travers des mouvements politiques comme
les loups-gris par exemple des violences
exercées sur notre sol donc en fait on
est dans une situation très ambiguë
là-dessus
donc oui il faut une coopération avec
l'OTAN bénéficier de l'expertise de
l'OTAN mais sans aucune forme d'illusion
sur l'ensemble des acteurs de l'OTAN et
notamment sur la question du
gouvernement turc il y a on a aussi
travaillé dessus et d'ailleurs à chaque
fois qu'on aborde ça ça pose un
problème avec nos amis de l'OTAN ça
c'est c'est une évidence et c'est un
immense problème d'ailleurs on le voit
même là sur le processus d'adhésion de
la Finlande et de
et de la Suède
mais au-delà de ça
on a
rencontré à plusieurs reprises la
question de des ingérences du
gouvernement turc dans les affaires en
Allemagne ou en France
et ça c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est assez paradoxal
pour un allié
au sein de l'OTAN
alors nous elle est chez européenne on a
la question de la Hongrie après
au sein de l'OTAN il y a la Hongrie vous
avez raison et il y a la Turquie et
c'est extrêmement problématique
sur l'Inde je précise sur l'Inde c'est
le rapport d'activité c'est pas non le
rapport final mais le rapport d'activité
publique aussi
c'est quoi ce rapport d'activité par
rapport au rapport final
alors le rapport d'activité c'est l'état
des lieux de tout ce qu'on a fait donc
c'est le compte-rendu et le rapport
final faut le consensus des groupes
politiques il est négocié par les
rapporteurs et en gros il faut une
majorité le rapport d'activité c'est
vraiment un compte rendu factuel
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas de donc c'est
parce qu'on a fait une audition sur
l'Inde qui a un compte rendu de
nos travaux sur l'Inde
mais le document qui fait loi
c'est le rapport qui est voté
merci Monsieur François 1er chassagnol
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
madame le rapporteur monsieur Glucksman
monsieur le Président alors vous a dit
vous alliez rompre avec la légèreté et
la naïveté c'était l'objectif de votre
commission alors je vais évidemment pas
remettre en cause le travail imminent
qui a pu faire votre commission mais je
viens de taper sur Google parce que vous
avez parlé d'une grande réunion secrète
en 2014 à Vienne avec des thématiques
qui qui seraient des grandes alliances
autour de Vladimir Poutine alors je le
tape 2014 grande alliance évidemment je
ne trouve rien à part un article du
Figaro qui donne le titre exact de cette
conférence à laquelle je vous rassure je
n'ai pas assisté l'avenir des valeurs
fondamentales et de la civilisation
chrétienne en Europe comme la famille
donc c'est une thématique autour de la
famille consiste à signer pour une
grande alliance et pas tout à fait
compris donc je vous enverrai l'article
du Figaro donc c'était le 31 mai 2014
rassemblement cette réunion donc je suis
pas tout à fait sûr de la source de la
citation que vous avez juste avant et je
vais continuer mon propos alors le 9
décembre 2022 un scandale de corruption
inédit par son ampleur et impliquant
notamment le Maroc le Qatar avait été
révélé alors plusieurs zéro députés
figurent notamment parmi la liste des
accusés en effet les services de
renseignement
un sujet du Qatar mais également du
Maroc ils sont tous proches de
l'Alliance progressiste des socialistes
au Parlement européen alors je posais
une une question je vous citerai
évidemment pas la parabole de la de la
paille de la poutre mais pensez-vous
encore être légitime à présider une
commission spéciale au titre exact sur
la gérance étrangère dans l'ensemble des
processus démocratiques de l'Union
européenne alors même que vous n'avez
pas été capable quand je dis vous je
parle de vos services de la Commission
en entier de découvrir au coeur du
Parlement européen un scandale de
communication un scandale gigantesque
alors je dis aussi ça parce que vous
êtes membre de la Conférence des
Présidents des présidents de commission
vous faites aussi partie du bureau du
Parlement européen de manière
exceptionnelle et de la Conférence des
Présidents donc je ne comprends pas
comment est-ce que votre commission et
vous-même n'avez pas pu voir un tel
scandale et je ne mentionnerai pas le
fait que évidemment vous étiez tous vous
êtes partis vous faites partie du Parti
socialiste européen donc vous siégé
également dans le groupe de ces
personnes
alors d'abord sur la réunion de Vienne
vous racontez n'importe quoi mais c'est
pas c'est pas très grave parce que vous
allez sur google mais enfin je vous
invite peut-être je sais pas j'ai pas lu
cet article mais
je vous invite à lire l'article originel
c'est en langue allemand c'est voilà
donc c'est
je sais pas si dans l'article que vous
mentionnez ils font ils parlent de
Monsieur doughin de
donc
cette cette réunion avait sous l'égide
de malofiev qui je le rappelle à
l'époque est le principal financier des
groupes paramilitaires qui font la
guerre dans le bon basse donc ça en
chacun choisit ses alliés monsieur vous
pouvez tout à fait défendre le fait de
répondre à son invitation avec
l'ensemble des extrêmes droits
européennes mais c'est pas c'est pas
anodin
sur sur la question maintenant du
catargate
alors
la première chose c'est que
je me suis opposé mais je ne savais pas
qu'ils étaient corrompu ou qu'il y avait
des suspicions de recevoir des valises
de billets je me suis opposé aux gens
qui au sein du groupe étaient partisans
d'une ligne
douce et compréhensive sur le Qatar
je me suis opposé en groupe j'ai demandé
à la délégation française de voter pour
la proposition c'était Manon bridge je
pense qui a avait proposé un débat sur
la construction des stades sur le Qatar
donc de voter contre la ligne groupe et
par ailleurs
nous avons toujours eu une position
extrêmement ferme sur le Qatar
maintenant
sur la question pourquoi est-ce que
votre commission n'a pas pu voir
qu'il y avait des valises de billets qui
étaient échanges parce que nous n'avons
pas la capacité mais peut-être que la
vôtre là je ne sais pas et là ce nom de
mettre sur écoute comme les services
belges ont fait des des députés ou des
ou des ou des anciens députés ou des
syndicalistes ou je ne sais pas des
représentants de fausses ONG que nous
n'avons pas de pouvoir d'enquête
policière ou judiciaire
et que donc nous ne pouvions pas savoir
qu'en dehors du Parlement s'échangeait
des valises de piège je le vois pas
comment notre commission aurait pu s'en
rendre compte
je veux dire si vous
réfléchissez deux minutes
comment
on peut
être informé du catargate sans
l'action extrêmement louable de la
justice et de la police belge les
services de sécurité belges qui ont
révélé le catégorie
donc je vous laisse à votre campagne
politique puisque c'est exactement la
même chose que le groupe idée a déclaré
au sein de
l'enceinte du Parlement européen mais si
vous voulez ça me trompe personne votre
partie votre groupe au Parlement
européen et opposé à la création de
notre commission depuis l'origine et on
sait tous pourquoi
on sait pourquoi vous ne vouliez pas de
commission spéciale du Parlement
européen pour enquêter sur les
agissements du régime de Vladimir
Poutine vous ne le vouliez pas donc
aujourd'hui que vous essayez de le
remettre en cause parce que il y a eu le
cas tardgate c'est juste la poursuite de
votre opposition systématique des gens
de votre groupe n'est ce pas siège
soi-disant parlant dans notre commission
nous les avons jamais vu
et ensuite on a des campagnes contre
notre rapport donc je pense que ça ça
relève de la campagne politique parce
que sinon ce que vous estimez c'est
qu'en gros il aurait fallu que nous
sachions ce que les services belges
étaient en train de découvrir en suivant
les personnes qui ensuite ont été
incriminées ce qui compte je pense c'est
la manière dont nous réagissons
et là-dessus notre commission a été
extrêmement claire peu importe le groupe
et c'est pour ça je veux dire là où vous
faites erreur quand vous vous attaquez à
notre commission c'est que en réalité
depuis le début
nous ne prêtons pas attention à la
couleur politique
des
groupes ou des personnes ou des parties
sur lesquelles nous avons à travailler
et dans le rapport vous noterez que il y
a des personnalités qui sont de gauche
ou de droite qui sont mentionnés et donc
comment on réagit un tel scandale est-ce
qu'on essaie de le couvrir est-ce qu'on
essaye de où est-ce qu'on essaye et bien
1 de faire en sorte que la vérité puisse
éclater de la manière la plus totale
possible et de est-ce qu'on prend en
compte ce qui sait ce qui s'est produit
pour changer ce qui a permis non pas la
corruption en tant que tel parce que ça
on pourra jamais empêcher
les gens de prendre des valises de
billets par contre on peut tout faire
pour que ces gens là et le moins
d'influence possible au sein des
institutions démocratiques et là-dessus
nous proposons des réformes ambitieuses
qui j'espère feront consensus
et
et seront mises en place avant la fin de
notre mandature
merci Madame chassagnol
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup monsieur le député pour la
clarté de vos propos j'aurai trois
questions la première sur la situation
d'influence continue ou de
déstabilisation des démocraties qui
s'apparent très si j'ai bien compris
selon vous un état de guerre est-ce que
parce qu'on est dans cette dans cette
situation d'influence donc de quelque
chose de licite ce que selon vous il
faudrait qu'on revoit la frontière entre
ce qui est licite et illicite étant
donné que c'est pas la première fois
d'ailleurs dans cette commission
d'enquête qu'on voit que c'est c'est
cette frontière qui parfois peut poser
question et également dans les dans les
mesures qu'on peut mettre en oeuvre pour
essayer de lutter contre ces ingérences
voir contre ces influences la deuxième
question un peu subsidiaire c'est sur
l'influence sur les réseaux sociaux
est-ce que dans la mesure où ça va être
une influence sur les valeurs
démocratiques sur parfois les sur les
mœurs sur des orientations politiques
vous avez parlé
du nationalisme qui peut être pousser
également
à partir du moment où ce sont des choses
qui sont là aussi de l'ordre de
l'influence est-ce qu'il faut porter une
attention spécifique à ces sujets là ou
est-ce qu'il faut réellement les
condamner et dans ces cas-là c'est une
réponse différente qu'il faudrait qu'il
faudrait apporter sachant que dans un
état démocratique on a aussi pour
ambition de d'assurer la pluralité des
opinions même si on est tous ici
d'accord pour constater qui vous nous
l'avez vous nous avez apporté aussi des
éléments précis concernant des
manipulations organisées dans nos
démocraties mais donc à quel moment on
peut mettre une limite pour dire que
quelque chose est interdit à partir du
moment où il s'agit aussi d'opinion qui
sont qui sont diffusés la dernière
question c'est au sujet de du
financement d'association
au-delà des partis politiques des
associations qui peuvent avoir aussi une
vocation d'influence sur un territoire
qui peuvent être financés d'ailleurs ou
simplement appuyer par certains moyens
est-ce que vous avez des exemples
des en tout cas est-ce que ça vous est
remonté qui avait cette appui à des à
des associations qui pouvaient faire un
travail d'influence de rencontres de
personnalité parfois de d'influence
culturelle aussi dans un premier temps
puis ensuite
d'assurer davantage de rencontres voir
de la corruption par la suite je vous
remercie
beaucoup
sur
la déstabilisation de démocraties et la
guerre hybride c'est justement une
guerre hybride c'est à dire que c'est
tout le problème c'est à dire que c'est
pas l'état classique de guerre et c'est
pas non plus l'état de paix donc c'est
un entre deux de conflictualité radicale
qu'il est très difficile de qualifier en
fait on a plus on n'a pas les les
éléments pour les catégories pour pour
le faire donc oui ça pose la question
d'une redéfinition de ce qui est lucide
et ce qui ne l'est pas
un exemple concret qu'on se pose
d'ailleurs qui a un débat au sein de
notre commission depuis longtemps
c'est la question de que font nos
dirigeants une fois qu'ils arrêtent
d'être nos dirigeants
est-ce que on interdit à nos dirigeants
de travailler dans le privé
faire des des gens se tipendiers à vie
avec comme condition de possibilité
d'existence le fait qu'ils aient trahi
nulle part donc on peut pas faire ça par
contre l'état actuel des choses
pose un problème grave c'est à dire que
si le chancelier allemand qui décide de
la politique énergétique européenne peut
aller travailler pour le principal
bénéficiaire de ses choix dans l'instant
ça pose un problème de sécurité de
souveraineté donc la question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on rend illicite
là dessus le débat et je pense que j'ai
pas une position majoritaire donc je
peux parler en mon nom je pense qu'il
faut assumer que aller travailler pour
une entreprise de je sais pas de tulipes
au Pays-Bas ou une entreprise de bois en
Norvège n'est pas la même chose que de
travailler pour Gazprom
mais ça ça suppose d'établir donc des
listes
d'entités dangereuses
je pense que un investissement et c'est
la même chose sur les investissements un
investissement de
céréalier brésilien ou de Costco ça
représente pas le même risque
pour notre soin et donc il faut
à mon avis établir des critères
objectifs qui
permettent ensuite d'établir des listes
d'entités pour lesquelles nos
gouvernants ne peuvent pas les
travailler
c'est une redéfinition du lycée en
l'occurrence et ce qui supposerait
d'assumer une forme de conflictualité
politique ensuite avec le régime chinois
le régime russe en l'occurrence si si on
prend c'est deux compagnies là c'est
pour ça qu'il y a une très forte récit
réticence si vous voulez à le faire
parce que je comprends le caractère
explosif politiquement de la publication
de telle liste d'entités problématiques
mais il n'empêche que
sans réflexion là dessus on ne trouvera
pas de solution parce que c'est pas
honnêtement aujourd'hui on parle de six
mois de période de refroidissement c'est
une discussion un débat qu'on a au
Parlement européen c'est à dire pendant
laquelle vous ne pouvez pas aller dans
une entreprise qui fait du lobbying
auprès du Parlement européen pendant les
six mois qui suivent la fin de votre
mandat
c'est très faible comme type de mesure 6
mois c'est le temps de digérer votre
défaite électorale de partir en vacances
et vous revenez vous installez ça change
pas grand chose en réalité
si garage avait dû attendre six mois au
lieu de trois mois je vois pas en quoi
l'histoire aurait été totalement
différente donc oui je pense qu'il y a
une vraie réflexion à faire il faut
faire attention quand on fait évoluer la
distinction entre le lycée il faut
toujours prendre des pincettes c'est
compliqué c'est je dis pas que c'est
d'un coup de baguette magique mais par
contre il y a une nécessaire réflexion
de la représentation nationale et là
prend des tentation à l'échelle
européenne là-dessus
sur la question du c'est toute la
ligne de crête en fait de notre travail
de depuis le début sur la question
du respect de la pluralité des opinions
qui constitutive et même de la
relativité de notre rapport à la vérité
depuis les Grecs anciens on sait que la
démocratie elle se fonde sur le fait que
on n'a pas un rapport
dans l'espace public religieux à la
question de la démocratie de la vérité
c'est à dire que je dois pouvoir
accepter que vous ayez un rapport à la
vérité distinct du mien et c'est ça qui
fait le débat démocratique
donc on doit pouvoir se protéger tout en
préservant cette pluralité là
moi j'explique toujours que
si vous pensez que la terre est plate
c'est pas le problème de notre
commission
vous avez parfaitement le droit de
penser que la terre est plate je peux
trouver ça moi très ridicule et
problématique
mais en tant que législateur c'est pas à
moi de vous expliquer que vous avez pas
le droit de penser que la terre est
plate
par contre si un État étranger
organise une campagne pour que vous
pensiez que la terre est plate et que
non seulement vous mais des centaines de
milliers ou des millions de concitoyens
pensent que la terre est plate là ça
devient un problème pour le législateur
et pour
les gardiens de la cité si vous voulez
et donc
moi je pense que c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que je
préfère le terme de campagne de
manipulation de l'information
à ce qu'on appelle les fake news parce
que
que on a le droit de se tromper de
partager des informations fausses on a
le droit
même d'avoir un avis qui contredit le
consensus scientifique
ce que il faut rendre illicite c'est la
possibilité pour des acteurs organisés
en particulier des régimes étrangers
de monter des campagnes qui visent à
induire en erreur
la population c'est ça qui qui pose
problème donc moi pour moi c'est même
pas la nature des opinions après il y a
des opinions qui sont rendus illicites
mais déjà par le droit français tel
qu'il existe mais
nous notre action doit se focaliser sur
le caractère organisé systémique
systématique pour servir des intérêts
étrangers
d'une propagation de certaines opinions
sur le financement des associations oui
nous on a
et d'ailleurs on continue à le faire on
a travaillé là-dessus
c'est évident que il y a un problème
dans le financement de certaines
organisations de la société civile mais
aussi de Sinta
et que on doit avoir pour
le caractère
si vous voulez honnête du débat public
des informations quand un thinktek qui
est financé par un régime étranger c'est
logique qu'on puisse le savoir parce
qu'ensuite quand vous allez produire une
analyse
je pense que l'origine des fonds
peut parfaitement entrer en ligne de
compte au moment de produire de
l'analyse ça c'est ça me semble être la
pure logique donc là dessus c'est pas
une question non plus de
disciples c'est une question de
transparence
et ça c'est important on cherche à faire
évoluer justement le règlement du
Parlement européen là-dessus
et sur la nécessité de transparence des
organisations qui viennent par exemple
témoigner
au Parlement européen et sur les
requêtes qu'on a sur leur niveau
justement de transparence
c'est ce qu'on appelle le registre de
transparence
merci monsieur Brun
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Glucksman on vous écoutant et
en écoutant le style déroulement de
cette audition je m'interroge
effectivement sur les difficultés que
nous rencontrons nous commissions
d'enquête française vous commission
spéciale tu parles le nord-européen pour
effectivement enquêter sur ces sujets
d'ingérence et sur la frontière traitée
nue avec celle de l'influence et je ne
peux que constater dans cette commission
à laquelle je participe de manière plus
ou moins assidue que je n'ai toujours
pas compris sur quoi nous enquêtons ce
que nous cherchions et je ne vois pas
non plus ce que nous avons trouvé
jusqu'ici
et quand on voit les moyens limités qui
sont les nôtres la tentation est grande
de la part des forces politiques et
composent cette commission et en
particulier celle qui en est à l'origine
d'utiliser cette commission comme un
moyen
d'attaque politique quand ce n'est pas
une attaque politique de ce blanchir en
tout cas de ce départir d'accusation qui
ont pu être faites d'ingérence ou en
tout cas de complicité d'ingérence à
leur endroit et j'en veux pour preuve
l'audition que nous avons eu la semaine
dernière de Monsieur Thierry Mariani
audition dans laquelle nous ne pouvions
poser aucune question dérangeante
pouvant finalement révéler mécanisme
d'ingérence puisque tout cela est
couvert par la justice et qu'il y a des
enquêtes en cours
nous ne savons toujours pas ce que nous
cherchons nous savons toujours pas ce
que nous allons trouver et j'ai le
sentiment que finalement dans votre
travail aussi au Parlement européen il a
été difficile de révéler des mécanismes
précis autre ce que nous connaissons
déjà aujourd'hui et le reproche qui vous
a été fait par mon collègue mon voisin
qui est parti opportunément après avoir
posé sa question
le reproche qui vous est fait de ne pas
avoir révélé le Qatar gate et finalement
profondément fondée comme on peut on est
fait vous reprocher de ne pas voir les
mêmes moyens que ceux de la justice donc
la question que vous posez chez le
président de Glucksman les commissions
que nous auxquelles nous participons la
française l'européenne sont-elles
finalement le bon endroit pour révéler
l'efficacement les mécanismes
d'ingérence à l'œuvre dans nos pays
européens
merci merci beaucoup de votre question
j'avais noté aussi le départ suite à la
production d'une vignette Twitter le
député
mais ce que je ce que je pense c'est que
nous n'avons pas de capacité de
révélation
que peut avoir les services de sécurité
les services de police
vous me démentirez si vous les avez mais
je pense que nous les avons ni au
Parlement européen ni
à l'Assemblée nationale et d'ailleurs
nous les avons beaucoup moins par
exemple qu'une commission d'enquête du
Sénat américain
qui a un pouvoir d'enquête avec des
fonctionnaires qui enquêtent réellement
qui est donc je crois avec une autorité
enfin qui ils ont une police même pour
enquêter
au service de ces commissions donc c'est
pas le même type de choses qu'on peut
attendre de nous
par contre on peut déjà établir un
diagnostic des menaces parce que nous
avons cherché à faire des attaques
répertoriées et essayer de comprendre la
cohérence des phénomènes qui ne peuvent
nous sembler épars auxquels nous faisons
face on peut aussi réfléchir en
interagissant avec des gens qui eux ont
des moyens d'enquête aux failles de nos
systèmes de sécurité
on peut enfin à mon avis réfléchir aux
évolutions législatives puisque c'est
notre rôle qui sont nécessaires pour que
ce soit mieux
pour que nos démocraties soient mieux
défendues puisque font c'est quand même
notre mission
la plus sacrée celle
en essayant c'est tous pour des parties
différentes engagés
en politique on a aspiré à la
représentation à l'échelle européenne au
National parce que on croit dans la
démocratie donc là il s'agit de défendre
le cadre même qui permet notre discensus
et nos conflits et nos débats mais
ce que nous nous cherchons à faire à
l'échelle européenne en plus et là c'est
une différence avec vous c'est
évidemment c'est que on gère 27
législation différente 27
rapports différents à la question et que
donc on cherche à établir une meilleure
coordination européenne une
harmonisation à l'échelle européenne si
on veut créer un espace politique commun
européen il faut que cet espace soit
protégé non pas exactement de la même
manière donc tous les pays européens
mais qui soient quand même protégé avec
une base de production
minimale dans chacun de ces pays et avec
une coordination assez
cohérente entre les différents
gouvernements européens donc ça nous on
a beaucoup travaillé là-dessus aussi
mais effectivement
si le rêve c'est de faire exploser les
scandales ça il faut compter sur la
justice et la police voir du journalisme
d'investigation dont je parlais tout à
l'heure
je pense que c'est pas fait un jeu à
cette commission de dire que elle ne
révélera pas plus que la nôtre
scandale caché grâce aux micro au
filature ou
au logiciel espion que vous n'avez pas
que nous n'avons pas non plus mais c'est
frustrant enfin moi honnêtement je vous
le dire de manière très franche je pense
que des démocraties parlementaires qui
se respectent
devrait prendre exemple sur une les
moyens qui sont alloués à une commission
d'enquête du Sénat américain
c'est pas c'est pas le cas chez nous et
c'est pas le cas chez nous
merci Monsieur Glucksman écoutez je ne
comprends pas ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui il y a des interventions de
tout le monde est libre de dire ce qu'il
veut et il y a aucune censure et
d'ailleurs c'est la ligne à laquelle la
présidente de cette commission qui agit
à mon nom propre et en tant que personne
d'autre
c'est tenu toutes les forces politiques
sont invitées au bureau toutes les
forces politiques peuvent intervenir
autant qu'elles veulent au bureau je ne
me suis opposé puisque c'est
compte-rendu de toute façon son public à
aucune invitation aucune toutes les
personnalités demandées par toutes les
forces politiques je vais voter je me
suis exprimé contre aucune invitation
donc il n'y a aucune tentative de la
présidence de cette commission
d'influencer les débats j'ai soutenu
toutes les demandes d'invitation
qui a été faite voilà sinon si opposé à
titre personnel en prison à aucune
toutes les questions que les
commissaires ont voulu poser depuis le
début de cette commission ont pu être
posée je n'ai interrompu personne donc
une force politique
interrompu sauf problème de vraiment de
longueur de tenue de la bonne tenue de
la commission par rapport au respect
d'un certain nombre de délai et
d'inviter suivant aucun invité je n'ai
jamais empêcher quelqu'un de tenir le
moindre propos donc je ne comprends pas
et par ailleurs pour ce qui est des
moyens attribués à la commission je me
suis attribué avant le droit de tirage
du rassemblement national j'ai exprimé
en commission des finances dans la
présence d'un nombre de personnes ici
que j'estimais que l'assemblée suite à
la mission d'information sur total et la
taxation des carburants que cette
assemblée n'avait pas les moyens
d'investigation j'estimais nécessaire au
niveau justement du Sénat américain donc
le publiquement une position qui demande
plus de moyens pour que cette ce
Parlement puis s'établir la vérité donc
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui mais chacun évidemment libre
de ses propos je passe sa parole à
Monsieur fever
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Député merci pour vos réponses oui je
vous rassure aussi nous ne sommes pas du
tout opposés à la constitution de
commission d'enquête sur le sujet des
ingérences puisque ça a été rappelé à
plusieurs reprises nous sommes
nous-mêmes à l'origine de cette demande
de commission ici moi aussi je suis
étonné un peu par les propos de monsieur
Brun d'ailleurs les auditions de la
commission étaient très intéressantes et
peut-être que si nous trouvons rien
comme l'ont démontré plusieurs experts
déjà du sujet c'est que la France est
peut-être bien préparée et armée contre
ces ingérences et si tel était le la
conclusion de notre commission je pense
que ça sera plutôt une bonne nouvelle
pour tout le monde et je suis aussi
étonné de votre marque soit ils sont
monsieur Mariani qui d'ailleurs je le
rappelle n'était pas présidé par le
Président
il veut revenir au sujet et c'est moi
qui suis garant de la tenue donc les
rétabli en tant que président et non pas
en tant que député à son monde national
gestimais l'éthique de cette commission
je l'ai fait maintenant je vous demande
de poser votre question à notre invité
oui monsieur le Président donc monsieur
le député dans votre rapport sur un G1
que j'ai lu il est écrit donc j'ouvre
les guillemets considérant que la Russie
cherche à établir des contacts avec les
parties personnalités et mouvements afin
de s'appuyer sur des acteurs des
institutions de l'Union pour légitimer
ses positions pour faire pression en
faveur d'un allègement des sanctions
pour atténuer les conséquences en
isolement international je ferme les
guillemets me pensez-vous pas que ça
c'est de faire un peu tous les pays du
monde et que ça s'appelle de la
diplomatie d'influence
mais surtout il est écrit juste après et
c'est l'objet de ma question
considérant que des parties telles que
la frite Leish a party Oster riches
autrichienne le rassemblement national
français la Liga du Nord italienne ont
signé
ont signé des accords de coopération
avec le parti Russie uni du président
Poutine alors ma question c'est quelles
audition et quels éléments vous ont
permis d'écrire cela
évidemment côté français etc national en
tout cas il n'y a jamais eu d'accord
signé entre nos deux parties et je
complète rapidement monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Glucksman vous
avez évoqué aussi dans votre propos
liminaire en utilisant l'expression
financement direct le prêt qui a été
accordé par la First sèche Bank aux
Front national en 2015 donc même
question je ne sais pas c'est ma
question si vous avez fait des auditions
sur ce thème et sur ce prêt dans votre
commission pour arriver à l'utilisation
de ce terme de financement direct qui
sous-entend quand même financement de
l'État russe alors qu'en tout cas les
auditions menées dans notre commission
jusqu'à maintenant ont démontrer que ce
prêt en plus d'être conforme je le
rappelle législation française de
l'époque est un prêt bancaire d'une
banque privée et qui n'était ça a été
d'ici par une personne au
pas du tout à des conditions favorables
et en tout cas moins favorables à ce qui
aurait pu être obtenu en France
alors sur la question du prêt déjà il y
a de près sur la question des prêts
j'ai précisé dans mon introduction mon
propos liminaire que ça faisait partie
des financements légaux
en 2021 quand on a réalisé une audition
sur la question le prennent était
toujours pas remboursé
et donc et c'est d'ailleurs ça avait
changé de main c'était je pense et vous
allez me démentir monsieur team chenko
non qui était qui avait hérité de près
enfin en tout cas il y avait eu une
évolution
et je veux pas dire de de fausses
informations là donc mais en tout cas il
y a eu une évolution dans la structure
de propriété des
de l'entité qui fait le prêt
et
du coup bien sûr que c'est légal
mais que
contracter un prêt et là quand vous
continuez à dire que c'est une entité
privée c'est encore une fois l'une des
leçons de tout notre travail c'est de
comprendre que dans le régime russe dans
la galaxie des oligarques qui gravitent
autour du Kremlin la notion d'acteurs
privés quand il s'agit de contracter un
prêt avec un mouvement politique en
Europe cette notion là n'existe pas en
Russie c'est pas la même chose que si
vous voulez une banque en France
et donc si vous êtes un acteur privé sur
le papier russe et que vous allez
contracter un prêt
avec un mouvement politique en plus dans
des c'est pas un mouvement politique
mineur je pense que vous allez
me dire que c'est un mouvement politique
majeur et donc dans un pays extrêmement
important du point de vue de la Russie
et bien vous n'agissez pas sans Laval
des autorités russes vous ne vous
agissez au service des autorités russes
et ça c'est le propre de ces régimes
ou c'est la même chose que ce que
j'expliquais au sujet des
investissements chinois de penser que
c'est simplement une boîte privée c'est
méconnaître la structure même de ces
régimes politiques et donc
vous pouvez continuer à penser que
ce prêt était légitime légal mais il
n'empêche que il a une connotation
politique extrêmement forte dans le
cadre d'un régime comme le régime russe
et que quand vous bénéficiez de ce prêt
vous êtes des facto dans une situation
où vous êtes l'obliger de celui qui vous
prête de l'argent c'est à dire le régime
russe
et ensuite sur la question
permettez-moi de vous poser donc la
première chose
vous m'avez dit
que le fait que la Russie cherche à
établir des contacts et à faire en sorte
qu'on lève les sanctions
c'était de la diplomatie d'influence
comme il y en a eu et il y en aura
toujours
certes
mais
cette propension
a considérer nos relations avec le
régime russe comme des relations
normales
justement conduit à ne pas comprendre
l'état de ces relations il n'y a pas de
relation normale avec un régime qui
change les frontières en Europe et qui
vise à mettre à bas l'architecture de
sécurité du continent européen il n'y a
pas de relation normale avec un régime
qui cherche à déstabiliser notre débat
public et à
déstabiliser nos démocraties et donc la
manière dont procède le régime russe
pour pousser son avantage
n'est pas juste de l'influence normale
et
[Musique]
ensuite sur les sur les accords de
commerçant juste je vous dis quand même
que la manière dont un rapport est
rédigé c'est pas le président qui note
l'ensemble du rapport je sais pas
comment ça se passe chez nous il y a un
rapporteur voilà donc là on a une
rapporteur donc c'est pour ça qu'à
chaque fois je me replonge dans le texte
je l'ai pas parfaitement en tête au
moins me réalinéa il y a un sur la sur
les accords il y a l'accord de de la
Liga avec le parti Russie unie
et c'est pareil pour
et donc il y a bien une confirmation qui
a le même type d'accord je sais pas à
quel niveau était cet accord pour le FPO
et le Front national à l'époque
donc vous avez des archives
alors normalement il y a pas
d'interpellation c'est pas un dialogue
non mais je le dis est-ce que
c'est une autre question monsieur fait
faire
oui monsieur le Président j'ai pas bien
compris votre votre réponse sur sur ce
dernier point parce que est-ce que parce
que vous écrivez quand même ça noir sur
blanc sur votre rapport donc ma question
c'est est-ce que ce sont vos auditions
ou votre commission d'enquête qui ont
permis de décrire ce fait noir sur blanc
est-ce que c'est un fait parce que
évidemment je le conteste tout à fait
une compétition tout à fait donc c'est
quand même important ce qu'on écrit dans
un rapport je sais que vous n'avez
peut-être pas écrit tout le rapport mais
en tout cas vous avez dû le relire
donc c'était basé sur des articles de
presse
cette phrase là je suppose
très bien
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur chers collègues
monsieur Glucksmann voudrait vous dire
que je trouve le travail que vous menez
extrêmement courageux et je ne doute pas
que quand on lève des questions aussi
fondamentales que celles que vous levez
ça ne doit pas être facile tous les
jours mais c'est tout à votre honneur de
le faire et donc vous avez mon soutien
un article du Figaro du cinéma on parle
beaucoup du figures aujourd'hui mais un
article récent du Figaro fait état la
mise en place d'agent dormants prorus en
Ukraine donc des Infiltrés qui étaient
là depuis longtemps en Ukraine et qui
était prêt à être activé le jour venu
donc
Poutine avec vraiment un plan concerté
et donc ça me ça me fait penser que
peut-être cette tactique elle s'est
aussi appliquée au Parlement européen
après l'annexion de la Crimée et puis
depuis le 24 février après l'invasion de
l'Ukraine donc est-ce que est-ce que
vous avez des éléments là-dessus vous
allez mentionné la réunion des droites
extrêmes d'Europe le 31 mai 2014 qui
avait été organisé par mallef à laquelle
participer Aymeric chou Prad député
européen rassemblement national et
d'autres et donc on pourrait imaginer
que ce type de réunion était aussi
avait aussi pour but la mise en place
d'agents dormants bon enfin après on
c'est peut-être de la fiction mais
j'aimerais avoir votre avis là-dessus
deuxièmement moi j'avais l'impression
que le Parlement européen était soumis à
toutes sortes de contrôles de
déclaration
on l'a vu avec les récentes affaires il
semblerait que non donc qu'est-ce que
vous proposez pour améliorer et surtout
prévenir les situations d'ingérence et
puis j'ai une dernière question j'espère
qu'elle ne sort pas du cadre c'est que
je siège à la PCE à l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe
pour laquelle j'ai fait une mission
d'observation des élections c'est une
institution très importante passionnante
46 pays qui comprennent l'Ukraine la
Turquie et d'autres donc au-delà des 27
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
institution pourrait aussi être sujette
à des tentatives ou même des des
ingérences réussies
sur les agents dormants par
définition si la question déjà je vous
remercie pour vos propos liminaires et
ensuite si la question c'est est-ce que
le même type d'agent dormant existe
d'ailleurs par définition c'est encore
une fois c'est les limites du travail
parlementaire c'est à dire que c'est pas
moi qui serait en mesure de les
identifier à la tête du secrétariat de
la Commission spéciale sur les
ingérences ce qui est sûr c'est qu'en
Ukraine en tout cas c'était parfaitement
organisé la présence des agents Normands
pas l'invasion
mais ça faisait longtemps que ces agents
étaient placés et qui étaient ensuite
appelés à sortir de l'obscurité au
moment donné
sur la question de
[Musique]
du contrôle au Parlement européen
il existe des contrôles au Parlement il
y a un registre de la transparence il
existe des déclarations d'intérêt il
existe mais
c'est mesures existantes sont bien trop
faibles et surtout
par exemple les pouvoirs de sanction
sont soit inexistence soit totalement
mineur et donc il faut réformer c'est à
ce à quoi on s'aime en ce moment et que
de ce que depuis l'interdiction des
groupes d'amitié quand des délégations
existent jusqu'au réglementation sur les
conflits d'intérêts tout doit
aujourd'hui être examiné et on va
produire je l'espère encore une fois
parce que c'est pas moi qui écrit
le rapport et je fais confiance à Madame
Loiseau et Monsieur BILS qui sont les
cours à porteurs
et qui ont déjà produit un draft et
ensuite aux différents groupes pour
avoir un une ambition forte de réforme
mais je pense qu'on sortira de cela avec
des changements sur tout un gamme toute
une gamme de mesure
la période de refroidissement qui fait
suite à votre mandat ne pas les
travailler pour une structure de
lobbying juste après votre mandat
ensuite utilisez vos réseaux au sein des
institutions pour influencer les
décisions
la création enfin à l'échelle des
institutions européennes de
d'une haute autorité de transparence de
la vie publique que malheureusement dans
la traduction on appelle etix body mais
moi je préfère le titre français en
l'occurrence
aux questions des
voyages et des visites parlementaires
bref à l'accès même au bâtiment européen
il y a énormément de sujets qu'on a mis
sur la table et qu'on est en train de
débattre je peux pas encore vous dire
par définition c'est la démocratie
où est-ce qu'on va aboutir sur ces
questions moi ce que j'espère c'est que
le gros le le la Commission soit la plus
ambitieuse possible sur ces réformes un
exemple la question des conflits
d'intérêt
vous pouvez être député et dans le même
temps
par exemple je sais pas que j'ai une
dent contre les avocats c'est pas du
tout le cas mais vous pouvez être député
à avoir un cabinet
qui travaille pour
Total par exemple
et
ça pose quand même question quand vous
êtes appelé à voter ensuite sur les
questions énergétiques mais je prends
cet exemple là je prends en prendre des
dizaines jusqu'ici il y a une
réglementation une régulation qui est
extrêmement faible
sur l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil
de l'Europe
il y a un excellent documentaire qui est
caviar connection je crois
sur la corruption au sein de l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe par
le régime de l'Azerbaïdjan
et mais c'était à quelques temps
et
mais ce documentaire est assez
intéressant parce que il est en règle
générale les enquêtes qui ont eu lieu
sur la caviar diplomatie de l'azerbée
Jean il montre comment finalement la
corruption
d'un
nombre limité de personnes au sein d'une
institution peut faire basculer des
majorités en l'occurrence le rapport qui
était parfaitement étayée sur les
prisonniers politiques à bas coût a été
rejeté par une coalition politique
alors même que l'orchestra principal de
cette
coalition politique de rejet était
financé ça a été prouvé par la justice
italienne ensuite par le régime donc il
y a
évidemment
cette menace qui plane toujours je sais
pas en fait à quel point l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe a
fait des réformes profondes suite
au scandale qui qui était lié au régime
de Bakou mais je pense que toutes les
assemblées sont menacées
évidemment et encore une fois vous avez
une très grande disproportion alors on
ne sait pas en l'occurrence il y a eu le
témoignage de l'ancien ambassadeur
d'Azerbaïdjan auprès du Conseil de
l'Europe et de l'Union européenne en
Suisse qui a dit que le régime de Bakou
avait dépensé je crois 30 millions mais
je me souviens plus du chiffre exact
en effort de corruption auprès de
députés mais on parle de régime qui sont
extrêmement riches et comme beaucoup
d'argent disponibles pour ce type
d'opération et par ailleurs on est
toujours nous sur les questions de
défense de nos institutions dans
l'impression d'être pauvre
et avec des budgets contraints
et donc on est
effectivement dans une situation qui est
pas toujours une situation de force pour
contrôler ça et donc au moins ce que
l'on peut faire c'est réformer nos
règlements pour rendre la chose la plus
difficile possible et si on n'arrive pas
à bannir toute forme de corruption au
moins limiter au maximum l'impact
potentiel de fait corruption sur la
manière dont sont décidé les choses
dans nos institutions
[Musique]
sur le PSG pour répondre rapidement sur
le PSG
non je faisais juste dans une interview
je crois par de mon problème d'anciens
fans PSG quand le PSG a été racheté par
le
Qatar donc c'était pas un sujet de
d'enquête de notre commission
il se trouve que
connaissant la nature politique du Qatar
et par ailleurs étant un amoureux de
football j'avais dit que ça me posait à
moi un problème effectivement mais ça
c'était mon confort personnel qui est
mes opinions personnelles
sur
le
sur le sur le sur le katargate on avait
auditionné avant les services belges
évidemment enfin on avait eu une
audition avec les services belges à huis
clos
mais on n'avait pas parlé je parle sur
notre contrôle c'est avant le 14e mais
il nous avait pas parlé du tout du Qatar
mais je suppose enfin en fait j'en sais
rien je vous le dis on interprétation
c'est aussi que ils avaient une enquête
qui était extrêmement discrète
menée et que la dernière
le dernier lieu où il viendrait en
parler c'est bien le Parlement européen
puisque le Parlement européen était
l'objet de l'enquête des gens du
Parlement européen était l'objet
d'enquête donc c'est toute la limite
encore une fois une commission de
parlementaire c'est à dire que
ils avaient bien conscience que
non il y a pas de serment
non il y a pas il y a pas de sens
mais
objectivement je comprends la logique
des services belges à ce moment-là alors
qu'ils font une enquête parce que
personne ne soupçonne au sein des
institutions européennes je veux dire il
aurait été compliqué donc maintenant
est-ce qu'on avait rencontré le Qatar
oui est-ce qu'il y a eu des conflits
politiques sur la question du Qatar oui
est-ce que
à des moments donnés des prises de
position semblaient
vraiment lunaire s'agissant des droits
sociaux au Qatar par exemple évidemment
et j'ai le souvenir moi d'une discussion
par exemple en groupe extrêmement dur
sur la question de la construction des
stades
à la veille de la Coupe du monde c'était
donc peu de temps avant la révélation du
Qatar gate
est-ce que on a eu nous vend à aucun
moment en fait on pouvait soupçonner le
Modus opérandit et l'ampleur du réseau
donc encore une fois on a interagit oui
avec les services belges par contre ils
nous ont pas parlé et on comprend
pourquoi ils nous ont pas parlé à ce
moment-là enfin pour ils en parlerait
pas au Parlement européen et d'ailleurs
je pense à
personne d'autre que même ou voir
peut-être à des services amies mais
c'est bien les seuls institutions avec
lesquels il parlait à l'époque
sur la question
sur Paris on a auditionné Monsieur
Christian Chinon
avec George Michael Bruno ils ont écrit
plusieurs livres sur la question et le
témoignage que je posais au début
c'était extrait de leur livre et de
l'audition sur le fait que l'ancien
ambassadeur se plaignait d'être
considéré comme un distributeur de
billets de 500 euros
je pense que le livre est toujours à
disposition il est intéressant à lire et
est-ce que j'ai des informations de je
pense que j'aurais moins d'informations
que vous là dessus parce que comme je le
disais nous on a 27 pays
à étudier ce qui nous laisse beaucoup
moins de temps pour malheureusement
étudier le cas français spécifiquement
on peut
on a réussi à avoir justement une
audition qui traitait aussi de Paris
parce que Paris est connu en Europe
comme étant l'une des places fortes de
l'influence gatari après je sais pas
quels ont été les mesures qui ont été
prises et je crois que d'ailleurs
l'attitude des successeurs de
l'ambassadeur dont je parlais était plus
ou moins différente c'est-à-dire que
c'était moins ostentatoire comme
influence qui a une certaine époque
et là dessus je peux pas moi vous
apprendre des choses je pense que c'est
plutôt l'inverse qui se produira
merci beaucoup pour votre question aussi
ce qui m'intéresse dans votre expérience
aussi pour éclairer nos travaux c'est
vous l'avez dit et de toute façon
presque
un consensus évidemment évident se
dégage sur le fait que les tentatives ou
les réalités d'ingérence sont
compliquées à identifier parce
qu'effectivement elles sont dans l'ombre
et leur efficacité dépend aussi
malheureusement de leur discrétion et
donc évidemment il y a des faisceaux on
essaie de percevoir des choses mais
aussi est-ce que vous on n'a pas aussi
la crainte parfois de se faire
nous-mêmes l'écho-déco c'est à dire qu'à
partir du moment où c'est dans l'ombre
et où c'est secret il y a une difficulté
aussi à faire la différence entre ce qui
devient elle-même un fantasme surtout si
ça s'étale sur plusieurs années par
exemple le cas du Qatar il y a des
scandale depuis un certain nombre
d'années
d'autres pays et
ma question porte par un sur un autre
paragraphe de votre rapport ou vos
établissez vous vous indiquez un certain
nombre de responsables politiques
d'ailleurs vous avez redonné l'essentiel
de la responsable politique aujourd'hui
et vous donner des noms je le dis
d'autant plus que c'est pas ma famille
politique donc pour ce qui concerne
notre audition notre commission pardon
il s'agit de l'ancien Premier ministre
français François Fillon qui a été nommé
Membre à l'époque du Conseil
administration de zahoo business il y a
aussi ensuite une deuxième conseil
d'administration et leur démissionnera
de ces deux conseils d'administrations
au début de la guerre de l'invasion de
la Russie de l'Ukraine vous citez
ensuite l'ancien Premier ministre
Jean-Pierre Raffarin le site qui promeut
activement les intérêts chinois en
France ensuite il y a d'autres il y a
des d'autres Européens et vous finissez
pour le cas de la France avec Jean-Marie
Le Guen membre du conseil
d'administration de Huawei France ma
question et c'est pour ça que je vous
parlais des écho déco c'est que vous
avez bien décrit le cas d'espèces de
garage frauder ou effectivement on peut
non pas établir factuellement parce que
ça c'est le rôle de la justice mais voir
un lien entre la politique énergétique
allemande et le conseil d'administration
de l'entreprise oui siège mais pour des
autres des autres personnalités dont
vous donnez le nom
je ne je dis plus de mal à percevoir si
vous voulez le lien évident d'ingérence
c'est à dire que comment vous pouvez
avoir la comment vous pouvez établir que
le fait de la position de Monsieur
Fillon
Raffarin et le gaine le mérite d'être au
même niveau que Monsieur Schröder ou
alors c'est la rédaction du rapport qui
fait ça et c'est une illusion d'optique
alors déjà je ne pense pas qu'il soit au
même niveau
peut-être que c'est une facilité de
rapport mais ils ne sont pas au même
niveau il n'empêche que ils sont partis
prenantes d'une stratégie d'un régime
étranger qui était de se transformer en
pourvoyeur mais c'est le cas aussi de la
Chine via ces grandes entreprises en
prouvant de retraite dorée vous pouvez
penser que c'est pas grave et que c'est
pas important mais je pense que si nos
dirigeants politiques ont comme horizons
le fait de
finalement être en relation avec la
Chine ou la Russie comme une future
banque qui le rassure leur niveau de vie
ils vont être amenés à prendre des
décisions qui ne sont pas nécessairement
très conflictuelles vis-à-vis de la
Chine de la Russie
j'emploie a des seins des littes et que
donc
il vont adopter une attitude conciliante
vis-à-vis de la Russie ou de la Chine et
que il faut arriver à briser cela parce
que ça aura un impact sur le type de
décision qu'on va prendre à la tête de
nos états donc je ne dis pas que c'est
au même niveau évidemment le cas
paroxystique c'est celui de garage
Schroeder
mais si on laisse s'installer parce que
les Russes eux-mêmes ont appelé la
redorarisation sur le
classe politique européenne on va droit
dans le mur
on a depuis le 24 février 2022 une prise
de conscience sur la question de la
Russie
mais je vous pose la question qu'est-ce
que on va faire dans quelle situation on
se trouver ces gens le jour où la Chine
envahit Taïwan
on dira ah là là qu'elle naïveté il faut
arrêter d'aller travailler pour ces
groupes
et dans le cas de Monsieur Fillon je
rappelle quand même que la décision
qu'il prend en 2021 d'aller travailler
pour des groupes qui sont mais
directement liés au régime au stade des
entreprises privées c'est Monsieur
c'est Monsieur Timchenko je crois qui
est le propriétaire et c'est des groupes
qui sont intimement liés au système
russe au système poutinien c'est une
décision prise au moment où le groupe
Wagner met une cible sur la tête de nos
soldats au Mali ou la France est la
cible numéro 1 de la propagande du
régime russe en Afrique
où ça a des risques extrêmement forts
sur notre pays et donc je sais pas moi
le minimum dans ce cas là d'éthique
patriotique devrait faire que ça
n'arrive pas il trouve il se trouve que
et ben ça arrive
et du coup il va falloir qu'on
légifère parce que sinon
on aura cette horizon là
de nos preneurs de décision
et je pense que c'est extrêmement
dangereux pour nos démocraties donc
c'est pas l'écho déco ce sont des faits
qu'ils ont travaillé enfin qu'ils ont
été travaillés pour Monsieur le Game
pour Huawei Fillon
donc c'est pas de l'écho de l'écho
peut-être que effectivement il y a une
différence de niveau avec le cas de
garage parce que ensuite il y a eu
dix années où il y a un Schroeder a
activement utilisé l'ensemble de ces
réseaux pour promouvoir des objectifs
énergétiques extrêmement concrets et que
donc on peut raconter cette histoire là
de manière inextino et qu'elle montre
cette histoire à quel point nous
démocratie sont friables
mais
les retraites dorées versées par des
régimes
qui sont hostiles à nos principes et à
nos intérêts stratégiques c'est un
véritable problème pour nos élites
ça touche les politiques mais ça touche
aussi
des capitaines d'industrie
ou des responsables d'écoles qui forment
l'élite française
et je crois que il faut qu'on s'y
attaque et qu'on s'y attelle
et que finalement
c'est une forme de
respect de soi pour une cité c'est à
dire que
quand
vous avez pu accéder à des fonctions
aussi hautes du Premier ministre de la
France
que vous devez vous réseaux finalement
et votre destin à la République
mettre au service vos réseaux
service
tyrannie étrangère
c'est franchement indigne et c'est
dangereux parce que
on ne parle pas de gens qui ont un
rapport extérieur au cœur même de nos
institutions et de notre état
mais aussi vous dénoncez un problème qui
reste dans la des gens évanescents
et donc il faut effectivement que les
gens aient une approche concrète que les
citoyens une approche concrète de ce
problème c'est pas des personnages
mythiques ou des entités philosophiques
ce sont des gens de chair et d'os qui
qui sont connus tous qui ont présidé aux
destinées de nos cités et qu'on décidait
de se mettre au service de tyrannie
étrangère dans les intérêts et les
principes sont hostiles aux nôtres si
j'étais romancier ou
metteur en scène j'explorerais leur
psychologie je me demanderais comment
ils font pour se regarder dans un miroir
mais c'est pas mon problème dans mon
problème c'est simplement de savoir quel
impact ça sur nos cités et comment nous
citer peuvent se prémunir de tels
comportements
merci mon avant-dernière question c'est
vous par exemple pour justifier le fait
que vous mentionnez l'ex Front national
rassemblant national comme partie
étant lié
je passe soutenant de narratif russe
enfin vous rétablirait la formule qui
vous semble pertinente
vous partez sur la base de quelques
exemples de d'euros députés monsieur
choprade mais moi monsieur Luvin
monsieur Mariani monsieur l'un à La
Capelle
et vous établissez de la présence de
Monsieur B la présence de ces personnes
dont une partie a quitté le parti entre
temps ou a été exclu mais c'est pas le
cas de la question vous allez voir
donc de la part de à partir pardon de
ces comportements individuels vous tirez
un comportement une application du parti
pour ce qui est des comportements
d'anciens Premier ministre donc ils sont
quand même pas on pourra reconnaître
Premier ministre et un eurodéputé c'est
pas vraiment la même influence dans un
parti politique monsieur Fillon a par
ailleurs été candidat à la
présidentielle et Monsieur Raffin aurait
pu l'être je pense qu'on peut le dire
sans danger voilà en tout cas été
premier ministre longtemps d'ailleurs
sous un mandat et je pense que sur ça on
se rejoindra ou des décisions de la
France en faveur d'investissement aussi
important ont été faits pour ce qui est
de Monsieur Raffin
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
vous ne tirez pas dans ce rapport sauf
erreur mais
du fait de la présence de Monsieur
Fillon un comportement général de l'UMP
ou des républicains et vous ne tirez pas
de la présence de Monsieur Raffarin un
comportement général de l'UMP aussi en
l'occurrence je sais pas s'il a été
républicain je ne sais plus je ne sais
plus où il est là et peut-être que enfin
en tout cas de la majorité enfin en tout
cas c'est un soutien de Monsieur Macron
et vous ne tirez pas de la présence de
Jean-Marie Le Guen un comportement
général du Parti socialiste puis aussi
un soutien de c'est un peu compliqué
parfois de suivre ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que de la même façon vous
tirez pas de Monsieur le fraudeur une
compromission générale du SPD allemand
sauf aussi erreur de ma part moi je pose
des questions de manière ouverte et
absolument pas donc ma question est
simple c'est pourquoi est-ce que vous
tirez à la base de personnalité
secondaire qui m'ont c'est pas leur
faire offense de partis politiques et
même parfois des gens qui sont plus dans
ce parti politique qui ont été exclus un
comportement général de la ligne du
parti et parfois de sa présidente et
vous ne tirez pas de personnalité aussi
imminente que d'anciens Premier ministre
un comportement général d'un
comportement général pardon de ce du
parti auquel il appartient ou dont il a
été le chef
c'est une question très intéressante
parce que
les
dirigeants des autres partis politiques
que vous avez évoqué
non pas conduit
correspondu leur partie n'a pas adopté
une position générale de soutien à
Vladimir Poutine
le Parti populaire européen
auquel
appartient ou appartenait l'UMP
appartiennent les républicains
à une position extrêmement ferme
vis-à-vis du régiment russe depuis
longtemps
et de la même manière le groupe de
garage Schroeder
groupe SMD a une position aussi assez
ferme et donc
la conjonction si vous voulez entre le
soutien politique et idéologique
exprimée par les dirigeants des parties
d'extrême droite et les actions ensuite
d'individus font une connivence générale
ça veut pas dire que dans ces mouvements
là tout le monde travaille pour la
Russie ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'il y
a une atmosphère générale qui n'est pas
le cas du PPE par exemple je prends
exprès défendre exprès devant vous une
famille politique et pas la mienne
si Monsieur Fillon accepte d'aller
travailler pour le régime russe pour le
système quotidien on peut pas dire que
ça détermine la position politique de
l'ensemble du Parti populaire européen
par contre il y a
dans les actions par exemple le fait que
il y ait ces députés qui ont été
sanctionnés de députés mineurs ils
apprécions mais c'est enfin de
personnalités politiques de
secondaire voilà pardon et bien c'est
député ils sont sur la ligne de leur
mouvement quand ils font ça ils sont en
rien avec une en rupture puisque à ce
moment là la dirigeante du Front
national
Madame Le Pen n'a rien à dire contre
l'annexion de la Crimée et à tout à dire
contre les sanctions qui sont prises à
l'encontre du régime russe et donc quand
il viole
l'égalité européenne en allant en Crimée
ils sont pas c'est pas des individus en
rupture avec le mouvement peut-être
qu'ils ont quitté mais pour d'autres
raisons c'est des raisons de politique
interne c'est pas sur la Russie qu'ils
ont quitté le rassemblement national
peut-être que peut-être que oui enfin je
suis pas un expert de des relations
internes de ce mouvement ils ne sont pas
en rupture avec la ligne idéologique et
géopolitique du mouvement
monsieur Fillon quand il va travailler à
ce moment-là pour le régime russe il est
en rupture claire avec la famille
politique du parti populaire européen du
point de vue européen c'est c'est
extrêmement
flagrant et donc c'est la conjonction
des deux qui fait que dans le rapport
c'est pas traité de la même manière pour
répondre à votre question
merci pour pour cette réponse oui vous
avez raison au niveau européen mais vous
avez
j'allais dire habilement mais c'est pas
le mot que je vais utiliser vous avez
choisi de répondre sur le sur le sur le
niveau des parties européens mais vous
avez aussi fait des commentaires en
France et c'est l'objet de notre
commission sur les parties français les
personnalités politiques françaises nous
trois entretiens vous avez d'ailleurs
tout à fait le droit en tant que
personne hypothy politique ça paye tout
une critique mais je reviens au sens de
ma question et c'est intéressant parce
que justement vous avez dit la position
des partis politiques dont j'ai cité les
noms donc Monsieur Fillon monsieur
Raffarin monsieur le gagne mais on peut
je te prends acte du fait que ces euros
député soit rendu dans un territoire
annexé de manière illégale ne conteste
absolument pas cette commission prend
tout à fait acte de ce que vous avez dit
par contre on peut aussi s'interroger
sur la proportionnalité entre le fait
d'aller censé toi et pour ce qui est
d'ancien Premier ministre d'ancien
ministre pour Monsieur Leguen le fait
d'attribuer
entre 2000 et 2020 par exemple de signer
un accord pour vendre un bateau
militaire le mistral d'autoriser total à
faire le plus grand investissement de
son histoire à Yamal d'autoriser Angie
qui est né avec 20% d'actions de l'État
d'investir sur gaz Nord streamer stream
2 plusieurs milliards d'euros en tout
cas un milliard d'euros pour nos stream
2 valider puisque les têtes actionnaires
d'autoriser Renault dont l'état est
actionnaire à hauteur de 10% à être le
premier un des premiers constructeurs
automobiles
en Russie je peux multiplier d'attribuer
à Monsieur Poutine la plus haute
distinction honorifique de notre pays
d'autoriser des personnalités mi-temps
de notre pays à recevoir des médailles
honorifiques du régime russe bref je
pourrais multiplier les exemples ou les
familles politiques appartenant aux
personnalité que je vous ai donné aussi
bien le MP le PS que la majorité
présidentielle ont accordé et pris des
prix des décisions politiques favorisant
le régime russe le reconnais
avec d'ailleurs des parfois des des
tragédie vous avez contesté avant
l'assassinat d'anapolitoscaia le
comportement du régime russe sans
cléclinis bref les crimes n'ont pas
manqué avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine
donc ma question je la repose en dehors
du contexte des parties européens pour
ce qui est des parties français
et de du fait que vous faites une
différence dans les parties français
entre comportement du rassemblement
national lié aux pratiques de ces euros
députés et des pratiques et la ligne
politique du rassemblement national à
partir de ces cas d'espèces vous ne la
faites pas sur la ligne politique des
autres parties particuliers par l'UMP
par Monsieur Fillon je crois n'a pas
contesté d'une manière différente la
situation de la Crimée
alors votre question elle posait sur le
rapport donc dans le rapport on est
obligé de parler de la situation
européenne c'est pour ça que ma réponse
était sur la question européenne et
c'est pas contesté votre réponse
repréciser ma question voilà et donc
maintenant on part sur mes interventions
dans un contexte de débat national donc
là je vais m'expriment en tant que
moi-même et non plus simplement en tant
que président de la commission parce que
s'il s'agit de justifier le rapport je
vous explique pourquoi cette traité de
cette manière là à l'échelle européenne
sur la sur la question nationale d'abord
la chose que je veux
rendre très clair c'est que
je n'ai pas dit
que par exemple les décisions prises par
Monsieur Schroeder je repars sur
l'Europe mais
on sans doute plus influencé l'histoire
européenne que les agissements de tel ou
tel mouvement politique qui n'était pas
au pouvoir
donc
si vous
lisez mon livre par ailleurs c'est le
point de départ sur cette question parce
que c'est pour moi le phénomène qui a le
plus d'impact sur l'histoire européenne
pour l'instant c'est ça
le
les actions dont vous parlez qui sont
prises je le rappelle parce que là vous
avez mentionné un apolith coffre chimie
mais qui sont prises après l'invasion et
le démembrement de la Géorgie en 2008
où la France décide par son gouvernement
et son président de vendre donc François
Fillon et Nicolas Sarkozy de vendre des
bateaux de guerre offensifs Mistral à la
Russie de la nuit en Poutine après le
démembrement de la Géorgie et le
non-respect par les autorités russes de
l'ensemble des points qui constituaient
le cessez-le-feu négocié par le
président français lui-même
et si jamais le président suivant
François Hollande n'était pas revenu sur
cette décision on aurait aujourd'hui des
bateaux français qui attaquent l'Ukraine
et donc ces décisions là sont
extrêmement graves
donc loin de moi l'idée de les minorer
une chose que vous pouvez me reconnaître
c'est que l'appartement politique de tel
ou tel acteur
ne
bloquera jamais
ma position critique à l'égard de tels
agissements puisque dans les mêmes
interviews où j'attaque le
positionnement du rassemblement national
je m'en prends aussi à des personnalités
éminentes de la gauche européenne sur
ces questions et que le fait que
Monsieur Le Guen par exemple a eu une
étiquette socialiste dans sa vie en rien
en ligne de compte quand il s'agit pour
moi de questionner ceux qui vont aller
travailler pour les intérêts chinois
donc
c'est ces événements sont tous graves
après sur la question du mouvement
politique en tant que tel
quand monsieur chafahauser va négocier
les prêts pour le rassemblement national
c'est le parti en tant que tel qui
devient débiteur
vis-à-vis de la First check Russian Bank
donc dans un élément du système Poutine
c'est plus une personne il a pas un prêt
personnel pour Monsieur chaffhauser il y
a le mouvement en tant que tel qui est
dans une situation de débit de dette
vis-à-vis d'un système qui est hostile à
nos intérêts fondamentaux et à nos
principes et donc c'est la différence
elle se fait là elle se fait aussi sur
le rapport à
à Poutine présentée comme
un
étendard politique
si vous voulez
vous pouvez reprendre les déclarations
des dirigeants de votre partie enfin là
je sais que vous êtes président de votre
partie vous pouvez reprendre les
déclarations des dirigeants sur Vladimir
Poutine et on est au-delà de oui vous
savez il faut bien discuter avec
Vladimir Poutine ce qui était une
position
défendue par les dirigeants d'alors et
qui conduisaient ensuite à des
compromissions on est dans l'exaltation
d'un agenda commun de mon point de vue
et donc on n'est pas dans le même
rapport exactement mais encore une fois
pour moi la stratégie russe russe
si vous voulez la stratégie russe depuis
des années elle a deux axes il y a
la corruption du système
et le soutien à des forces décrites
comme anti-système
et
là dessus le rassemblement national a
été instrumentalisé enfin le Front
national à l'époque comme force
remettant en cause le système existant
et la construction européenne et les
institutions européennes et donc dans la
stratégie russe il était un des éléments
mais les cas que vous avez cités étaient
parfaitement des éléments aussi de la
stratégie dans le gérance russe il y a
une stratégie qui a été fondée sur deux
axes
et ces deux axes étaient
sans doute
d'égal importance aux yeux des autorités
russes peut-être même que la corruption
du système lui-même était encore plus
importante
aux yeux des autorités
non je n'ai pas de question mais je
crois qu'on s'achemine vers softy
d'autres commissaires ont encore des
observations ou des interrogations vers
la fin de de cette audition que j'ai
trouvé extrêmement
éclairante alors après il y a des débats
que vous avez vous-même alimenter
monsieur le Président très
franco-français qui sont quelquefois
sortis du cadre
de la présidence de la commission
spéciale du Parlement européen qui
assume notre collègue Raphaël Glucksman
mais qui sont des débats tout à fait
intéressant je pense que il y a malgré
tout un sombre de travaux
d'investigation déjà menées par des
organes de presse nombreux depuis de
nombreuses années par exemple sur sur la
Russie et la stratégie que le régime de
Poutine a souhaité mener en direction de
cible appartenant aux familles
politiques de la droite extrême et de
l'extrême droite je pense à complément
d'enquête je pense à Spécial
Investigation
il y a beaucoup et c'est très documenté
beaucoup de d'ouvrages et d'ailleurs on
va pas manquer depuis les débuts de des
travaux de cette commission d'enquête
d'entendre des chercheurs des
universitaires des des gens qui ont
produit un centre de rapports dans des
thunes ou ailleurs qui viennent colorer
un ensemble de choses produite par le
journalisme d'investigation et voilà
nous savons le prix que paye souvent les
journalistes d'investigation d'ailleurs
à la recherche de la vérité et la
dénonciation l'ensemble de choses et
d'ailleurs en ce moment même voilà en
Russie il y a il y a un journaliste qui
paye très cher
sera pas sa pratique journalistique mais
je crois qu'il y a des débats que nous
aurons entre nous au moment peut-être où
il s'agira de discuter du projet de
rapport que que je serai amené à à
soumettre et puis de manière générale
quand même et ça je crois que l'audition
de Rafael gosmann a été très claire à
cet égard
la contextualisation que nous devons
avoir
pas uniquement d'un point de vue
géopolitique aux géostratégique mais
également du point de vue des valeurs
ensemble de systèmes sont en opposition
et sont animés par le désir de détruire
nos valeurs européennes nos valeurs
démocratiques il y a des régimes qui
sont des régimes autoritaires et
dictatoriaux se sont eux qui ont les
stratégies d'influence et d'ingérence
les plus brutales les plus violentes et
les plus sournoises en même temps et
d'ailleurs souvent très très massivement
financé et il y a des régimes qui ne
sont pas arrangés dans la catégorie de
celles et ceux qui s'en prennent à nos
valeurs démocratiques et à nos valeurs
européennes donc ça fait une vraie vraie
distinction et d'ailleurs on peut
souvent s'interroger sur la rationalité
de celles et ceux y compris quand ils
sont toujours en exercice qu'ils sont
par exemple membres du Parlement
européen ou membre d'un parlement
national quel qu'il soit français ou
ailleurs qui de ce fait devrait être
attachés aux principes même de la
démocratie parlementaire et de la
démocratie représentative et qui en même
temps sont extraordinairement alignés és
et en phase avec des positions
prenées par un par un régime
dictatorial ou autoritaires voilà mais
c'était commentaire que je voulais
apporter à ce stade
je vous remercie bien écoutez comme vous
l'avez d'ailleurs très justement dit
nous sommes donc à la fin de cette
audition je vous remercie encore
monsieur gussmann va être remercier
votre collaborateur pour votre présence
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
remercie l'administration pour
l'organisation de cette commission nos
collègues commissaires pour leur
présence et leur question et je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée je vous
souhaite aussi bonne chance pour la
suite de votre travaux puisque je sais
que même quand on a animé de bonnes
intentions il est trop difficile et
toujours difficile d'animer ses travaux
je vous remercie vous faites une bonne
soirée